As a young adult, finding the right path to your future can feel overwhelming.
作为一个年轻人，找到通往未来的正确道路可能会让人感到不知所措。
It starts with year-up unites tuition-free job training program career pathways.
它从一年级开始，统一了免学费的职业培训计划的职业道路。
If you're without a bachelor's degree but have a high school diploma or GED, you can get skills first training to succeed in the industries you're passionate about all while earning a weekly educational stipend to offset basic expenses.
如果您没有学士学位，但拥有高中文凭或 GED，您可以获得技能优先培训，以便在您热衷的行业中取得成功，同时获得每周的教育津贴来抵消基本费用。
From there, you'll have access to internships and hands-on experiences with Fortune 500 companies And with Year Up United's job placement services and personalized coaching and mentorship, you can put your knowledge, skills, and most importantly, confidence into practice.
从那里，您将有机会获得财富 500 强公司的实习机会和实践经验，并通过 Year Up United 的就业安置服务以及个性化辅导和指导，您可以将您的知识、技能，最重要的是，信心付诸实践。
Apply to Year Up United today and take the first step toward achieving the career you want.
立即申请 Year Up United，迈出实现您想要的职业生涯的第一步。
Visit YearUp.org to learn more.
访问 YearUp.org 了解更多信息。
Hey, Alec.
嘿，亚历克。
Hey, Josh.
嘿，乔什。
I'm pretty excited for this autumn, can I tell you why?
我对这个秋天感到非常兴奋，我能告诉你为什么吗？
Absolutely.
绝对地。
It's a lovely time in New York City.
这是纽约市的美好时光。
Well, yeah, I've got a new album coming out and I have a single that's coming out and it's called October.
嗯，是的，我有一张新专辑即将发行，还有一首单曲即将发行，它的名字叫《十月》。
What?
什么？
We're hearing about it right here for the first time.
我们在这里还是第一次听到这个消息。
So I'm very excited about the fall, about the autumn, especially the month of October.
所以我对秋天，特别是十月感到非常兴奋。
And not only am I excited about the music, I'm excited to get comfortable and cozy because that's what fall on the east coast or whatever place you are that has seasons is all about.
我不仅对音乐感到兴奋，而且也很高兴能够变得舒适和温馨，因为这就是东海岸或任何有季节的地方的一切。
And we don't need to argue about this.
我们不需要争论这个。
There are seasons in Los Angeles and every night it's fall.
洛杉矶有季节之分，每天晚上都是秋天。
That's true.
这是真的。
You need a light jacket if you live in California.
如果您住在加利福尼亚州，您需要一件轻便的夹克。
Where can you get those light jackets and those sweaters and those perfect autumn, comfortable and cozy pieces?
哪里可以买到那些轻便的夹克、毛衣以及完美的秋季、舒适和温馨的单品？
Might I recommend Quince, which sent me an incredible sweater that is in heavy rotation.
我可以推荐Quince吗，它给我寄来了一件令人难以置信的毛衣，而且经常轮换。
Also, I picked out one or actually Jordana picked it out, a sweater from Quince, that is also in heavy rotation.
另外，我挑选了一件，或者实际上是乔丹娜挑选的，这是一件来自 Quince 的毛衣，这件衣服也在大量轮换中。
So we are set for the fall.
所以我们已经准备好迎接秋天了。
We keep going back to these sweaters.
我们不断回到这些毛衣。
They work with almost our entire, I mean, our entire closet is just earth tones because that's kind of what we work with.
它们几乎与我们的整个衣橱搭配，我的意思是，我们的整个衣柜都是大地色，因为这就是我们的工作方式。
But it matches with everything.
但它与一切都很相配。
So we're delighted with our pieces from Quince.
所以我们对 Quince 的作品很满意。
And I think you would be too.
我想你也会的。
So upgrade your every day.
所以升级你的每一天。
Download the Quince app for app exclusive offers or go to quince.com slash your mother pod.
下载 Quince 应用程序以获得应用程序独家优惠，或访问 quince.com 削减你的母豆荚。
Get free shipping on your order and 365 day returns now available in Canada and the UK too.
加拿大和英国现在也提供订单免费送货和 365 天退货服务。
That's q-u-i-n-c-e dot com slash your mother pod.
这就是 q-u-i-n-c-e . com 削减你的母亲 pod。
Hi, I'm Lorenzo from Italy and I love how I met your mother.
你好，我是来自意大利的洛伦佐，我很高兴认识你母亲。
I could talk for hours about the show how it helped during really hard times but the last time I saw an episode Yes, of course, I realize that.
我可以花几个小时谈论这部剧在非常困难的时期是如何提供帮助的，但上次我看一集时，是的，当然，我意识到了这一点。
It makes me feel good, but not simply good because it's fun or whatever.
这让我感觉很好，但不仅仅是因为它很有趣或其他什么。
I'm talking about really good, such as when you listen to music that makes you feel alive, playing your favorite sport, eating a great pizza, such as when you are with the people you love.
我说的是真正的美好，比如当你听让你感觉活着的音乐、做你最喜欢的运动、吃美味的披萨，比如当你和你爱的人在一起时。
Because when you watch a amateur mother, it's so powerful that you feel you're part of the gang.
因为当你看到一个业余母亲时，它是如此强大，以至于你感觉自己是这个团伙的一部分。
And you feel like you are in the tense season and you don't know what happens then, but it also heals the little cracks in your heart.
你感觉自己正处于紧张的季节，你不知道接下来会发生什么，但这也治愈了你内心的小裂缝。
The show is written directly by Blitz, so splendidly with the plot and the jokes and details that at the end you watch any episode and for the 20 minutes you are happy.
该剧由 Blitz 直接编剧，情节、笑话和细节都非常精彩，以至于最后你看任何一集，都会在 20 分钟内感到高兴。
You have that stupid smile or a little tear on your face but also deep inside.
你脸上有那种愚蠢的微笑或一点点泪水，但内心深处也有。
You can't cling to the past but the past makes who you are.
你不能坚持过去，但过去造就了你。
Everything in New York City.
纽约市的一切。
Hello everybody, welcome to another very special episode of How We Made Your Mother, They're All Special.
大家好，欢迎收看《我们如何创造了你的母亲，他们都很特别》的另一集非常特别的节目。
That was so wonderful and so heartwarming, such a great way to kick off this episode.
这真是太棒了，太温馨了，这是开始这一集的好方法。
I think when we're exploring this mystery of why do people love How We Made Your Mother So Much, why do they keep coming back to it?
我想，当我们探索这个谜团时，为什么人们如此喜爱《我们如何成就了你的母亲》，为什么他们会不断地回顾它呢？
Why do they watch it 15 times over?
为什么他们会看15遍以上？
I think if he hit on the essential thing, it's an antidote to loneliness.
我认为如果他抓住了最重要的事情，那就是孤独的解药。
Yeah.
是的。
you feel like you have some friends you're rolling through the good times and the bad times with people.
你感觉你有一些朋友，你正在与人们一起度过美好时光和糟糕时光。
And I think we're in a real, you know, there's a lot in the UK and Japan, they have ministers of loneliness because there's such an epidemic of loneliness throughout the world right now.
我认为我们正处于一个真实的境地，你知道，英国和日本有很多人，他们有孤独感部长，因为现在全世界都在流行孤独感。
There's something about the way it's all structured and I think the phones and social media, like it's just everyone's kind of getting more and more siloed.
这一切的结构方式都有问题，我认为电话和社交媒体，就像每个人都变得越来越孤立一样。
And I think there's something almost like nostalgic about.
我认为这里面有一些类似怀旧的东西。
Oh my gosh, look, they're hanging out in real like no one's checking their phone.
天哪，看，他们真的在闲逛，就像没有人检查他们的手机一样。
I mean, phones were there.
我的意思是，电话在那里。
There's some phones, but there's some phones in how I made my way.
有一些电话，但有些电话影响了我的生活方式。
But they weren't obsessive about them.
但他们并不痴迷于它们。
They were more interested in in eye contact and how they could make each other laugh.
他们对眼神交流以及如何让对方发笑更感兴趣。
Yeah, and they were, well, we should say this is the episode where we talk about the pilot, right?
是的，他们是，好吧，我们应该说这是我们谈论试播集的一集，对吧？
We should say that right off the bat.
我们应该立即这么说。
Yeah, this is the pilot episode.
是的，这是试播集。
And one thing I loved rewatching the pilot which I hadn't watched in years, literally I had much in years.
有一点我很喜欢重看我已经很多年没看过的试播集，实际上我已经很多年了。
One thing I loved is Ted's awareness and kind of all of their awareness in the story of this is going to be a story we tell someday.
我喜欢的一件事是特德的意识以及他们在这个故事中的所有意识将成为我们有一天讲述的故事。
There's this idea that we are creating stories.
我们正在创造故事。
So the show is very conscious of its storytelling in the way that people kind of are.
所以这部剧非常注重以人们的方式讲述故事。
They're like we're having a night we're going to talk about and we're all that way and we're sharing that and when you share that in person and how go and have actual experiences doesn't run around to the bar and stealing Blue French horns and encountering this new woman with five dogs and you're on the adventure with your best friends.
就像我们正在度过一个我们要谈论的夜晚，我们就这样，我们正在分享，当你亲自分享时，如何去获得实际的经验，而不是跑到酒吧偷蓝色法国号并遇到这个带着五只狗的新女人，你正在和你最好的朋友一起冒险。
There is, God, there is this feeling of warmth in there and that's what Lorenzo was talking about.
天啊，那里有一种温暖的感觉，这就是洛伦佐所说的。
Lorenzo, thank you for your time.
洛伦佐，谢谢您抽出时间。
Yeah, thanks again.
是的，再次感谢。
So glad that it comes through to you.
很高兴它能传达给你。
I mean, look, Craig, they're self-mythologizing characters.
我的意思是，听着，克雷格，他们是自我神话化的人物。
They are.
他们是。
They're creating their own mythology much in the way that you and Carter talked about leaving New York City and feeling like, oh, this was a time in our lives.
他们正在创造自己的神话，就像你和卡特谈到离开纽约时感觉的那样，哦，这是我们生命中的一段时光。
want to like capture and rewind and reflect on.
想要喜欢捕捉、倒带和反思。
Yeah.
是的。
It's so conscious of itself as a story, the pilot.
飞行员非常清楚自己是一个故事。
I was delighted by that.
我对此感到很高兴。
It's so kind of postmodern.
这太后现代了。
And it's mostly through Ted.
这主要是通过特德完成的。
Like there was a line that really jumped out of me.
就像有一句话真的从我身上跳出来。
I mean, so much jumped out of me.
我的意思是，太多的事情从我身上跳出来了。
Mostly I remembered it all.
大多数时候我都记得了。
But every now and again, a line was like, oh, I was, I didn't remember that line.
但时不时地，有一句话就像，哦，我是，我不记得那句话了。
And Ted, there's a line from Ted that he says, like, you're going to tell this story at our wedding marshal right before he marches in to go to go freak out robin by saying I love you there a second encounter and one and he you know like that idea like this is going to be a story and by the way the story does not go the way Ted thinks that is not what happens but he was right it's going to be a story he's right it was going to be a story it's a big story I have a question for you is the pilot just called pilot yeah the pilot just called pilot it.
泰德，泰德有一句话，他说，就像，你要在我们的婚礼元帅走进去吓坏罗宾之前告诉他这个故事，说我爱你，第二次相遇，然后他你知道这样的想法将成为一个故事，顺便说一句，这个故事不会像泰德认为的那样发展，这不会发生，但他是对的，这将是一个故事，他是对的，这将是一个故事这是一个大故事，我有一个问题要问你，飞行员刚刚被称为飞行员，是的，飞行员刚刚被称为飞行员。
It's sort of disappointing.
这有点令人失望。
We probably should.
我们也许应该。
What would you call it if you could rename it?
如果你可以重命名它，你会叫它什么？
I think I would let Lorenzo from Italy title it.
我想我会让来自意大利的洛伦佐为它冠名。
Yeah, the cracks in your heart.
是啊，你心里的裂痕。
The cracks in your heart are healed by pizza.
你心中的裂痕可以被披萨治愈。
Oh, or the call of the ministers of loneliness.
哦，还是孤独大臣的召唤。
That's a cool.
那很酷。
That's a band name.
这是一个乐队的名字。
I wanted to write a song called the Minister of Loneliness to try it.
我想写一首叫《孤独部长》的歌来尝试一下。
That's fantastic.
太棒了。
It sounds like a balanced the song to bring it back to the show.
这听起来像是一首平衡的歌曲，将其带回到节目中。
It's such a bound Sebastian, right?
塞巴斯蒂安真是太受束缚了，对吧？
It's a bound Sebastian.
这是一个被束缚的塞巴斯蒂安。
Right, that song, if you're listening, or else we're going to, and it won't be as good as yours.
是的，那首歌，如果你在听的话，否则我们就去听，它不会像你的那么好。
So I was like, the Blue French horn would be a nice title.
所以我想，蓝色圆号会是一个不错的标题。
Maybe for this pilot.
也许对于这个飞行员来说。
Oh my God, God damn it.
天哪，该死的。
Why do you have to do that to me, Alec?
你为什么要这样对我，亚历克？
That's what it should have been.
本来应该如此。
I know.
我知道。
God damn it.
该死的。
I can't go.
我不能去。
We can't go back.
我们回不去了。
There's no going back.
没有回头路了。
You're going back, right?
你要回去了，对吗？
That's what we're doing.
这就是我们正在做的事情。
That's right.
这是正确的。
That's what this whole podcast is.
这就是整个播客的内容。
Can we just say it's called the Blue French horn?
我们可以说它叫蓝色圆号吗？
Yeah, it's from henceforth.
是的，从现在开始。
Can we retcon that in this?
我们可以在这方面重新讨论一下吗？
Yeah, so I watched the pilot also with Jordana, my wife, who's never seen the show.
是的，所以我也和我的妻子乔丹娜一起观看了试播集，她从未看过这部剧。
Oh, so I want to hear about the so bad, they're afraid from asking you much about this.
哦，所以我想听听那么糟糕的事情，他们不敢问你太多关于这件事的问题。
I want to know.
我想知道。
Yeah, well, you got to back this up a second, she loved him, we'll get to her.
是的，好吧，你必须支持这一点，她爱他，我们会找到她的。
But I also hadn't seen it in, I don't know, I mean, I don't know that I went back and watched it much after it was on.
但我也没有看过它，我不知道，我的意思是，我不知道在它播出后我回去看了很多次。
I think for some reason, I probably saw that episode the most times of any episode because we did a couple screenings of it.
我认为出于某种原因，我可能在所有剧集中看到这一集的次数最多，因为我们放映了几次。
We did.
我们做到了。
And then you end up at the upfronts where we debut the show for the advertisers you end up seeing a ton of clips of it.
然后你最终会到达我们为广告商首次展示该节目的前期，你最终会看到大量的剪辑。
So I actually knew the show pretty well.
所以我实际上非常了解这个节目。
Yeah.
是的。
And I was startled at how much it's still in my bloodstream.
我惊讶地发现它仍然存在于我的血液中。
Oh yeah, no me too.
哦，是的，我也没有。
Yeah.
是的。
I was watching it with Rebecca and my wife who also watched it 5,000 times at that time because it was just, we were, you work on that one episode for months and it becomes your entire life and then everything starts to move much faster that she said, I cannot believe how like off-book verbatim.
我和丽贝卡以及我的妻子一起看这部电影，他们当时也看了 5,000 遍，因为我们只是为了这一集花了几个月的时间，它就成了你的整个生活，然后一切都开始进展得更快，正如她所说，我不敢相信这有多像书外逐字逐句。
I still am on this pilot.
我仍然在这个试点中。
She knew every line of it.
她知道其中的每一行。
She was like, this must be a pretty good pilot because I know every freaking word of this thing.
她说，这一定是一个非常好的飞行员，因为我知道这件事的每一个奇怪的词。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
And I felt the same, except a couple of those moments that surprised me.
我也有同样的感觉，除了一些让我惊讶的时刻。
Well, let's talk a little broad strokes.
好吧，让我们谈谈一些大体的情况。
Like, what were your headlines?
比如，你的头条新闻是什么？
Like, what were the things that left out at you that you thought, I'm really proud of this or this is a great memory or tell me what your experience was like?
比如，你认为哪些事情没有发生，我对此感到非常自豪，或者这是一段美好的回忆，或者告诉我你的经历是什么样的？
I mean, it was, I was proud of how clear it was.
我的意思是，确实如此，我为它的清晰程度感到自豪。
It was like, it just had this clarity right away.
就好像，它立刻就变得清晰了。
And I remember that when we pitched the show, Carter and I, we talked a lot about this idea of like, Ted is in the center, caught between these two worlds.
我记得当我们推销这个节目时，卡特和我，我们谈论了很多这样的想法，比如，泰德位于中心，夹在这两个世界之间。
Barney is the devil on his shoulder and Marshall's kind of the angel on his other shoulder and he's sort of aspiring towards Marshall and Lily.
巴尼是他肩膀上的魔鬼，而马歇尔则是他另一只肩膀上的天使，他对马歇尔和莉莉有些渴望。
And it's his mad dash and his rush and jumping ahead and thinking he can just decide it and make it happen that is sort of the disconnect there.
正是他的疯狂冲刺、冲刺和跳跃，并认为他可以做出决定并使其发生，这就是那里的脱节。
And failing to get that immediately will sometimes send him back to Barney.
如果不能立即得到这一点，有时会把他送回巴尼。
And Barney will be the seductive other force away from the like a pretty bad idea.
巴尼将成为另一种诱人的力量，远离一个非常糟糕的主意。
With a terrible idea.
有一个可怕的想法。
And I was like this, but the simplicity, like Barney becomes so elaborate in series.
我本来就是这样，但是简单，就像巴尼在系列中变得如此精致。
But in the pilot, his whole story, he has two simple drives.
但在飞行员的整个故事中，他有两个简单的驱动器。
You can't even really call it a story.
你甚至不能称其为故事。
He has the presence because Neil is great in it.
他之所以有存在感，是因为尼尔在这方面表现出色。
And he's this larger than life character, but he just wants two simple things.
他是一个比生活更伟大的人物，但他只想要两件简单的事情。
It's not even a story.
这甚至不是一个故事。
He just wants Ted to put on a suit.
他只是想让特德穿上一套西装。
That's right.
这是正确的。
All he wants, he wants, I want Ted to put on a suit and he achieves that goal at the end.
他想要的一切，他想要的，我想让特德穿上一套西装，他最终实现了这个目标。
And he also wants, and I was really struck by this, and I was proud of this, because people do debate Barney.
他也想要，我对此感到非常震惊，我为此感到自豪，因为人们确实辩论巴尼。
You would Barney play nowadays, all that kind of thing.
现在你会扮演巴尼，诸如此类的事情。
And Barney, his other, his only other desire.
还有巴尼，他的另一个，他唯一的另一个愿望。
He's not chasing a woman in that episode.
在那一集中他没有追女人。
He's talking trash a little bit, but he really wants two things.
他说的有点垃圾，但他确实想要两件事。
The second of which is I want Ted to say him his best friend, which is the saddest and most vulnerable and sweetest kind of drive.
第二个是我想让特德说他是他最好的朋友，这是最悲伤、最脆弱和最甜蜜的一种动力。
He just wants to know he's important to Ted, which makes Ted important to the audience.
他只是想知道他对泰德很重要，这使得泰德对观众很重要。
And Marshall and Lily are like Ted's parents, you know, they're the same age, but they're home on the couch waiting to hear, how is your night out, son?
马歇尔和莉莉就像泰德的父母，你知道，他们同龄，但他们在家里的沙发上等着听，儿子，你晚上出去玩怎么样？
And so he's their son and he's important to them like he's their son and to Barney, Barney wants me to be his brother and Barney wants sole ownership over Teddy.
所以他是他们的儿子，他对他们很重要，就像他是他们的儿子一样，对巴尼来说，巴尼希望我成为他的兄弟，巴尼希望拥有泰迪的唯一所有权。
So jealous of me or so probably, I mean, Marshall being Ted's best friend.
我是说，很可能很嫉妒我，马歇尔是泰德最好的朋友。
It's not probably he knows it drives Barney so crazy that Marshall, I always like that.
他可能不知道这让巴尼如此疯狂，而马歇尔，我一直喜欢这样。
I always like that they fought over Ted as this kind of like prize trophy friend that, that always, I always thought that was very sweet.
我一直喜欢他们为特德而战，就像奖品奖杯一样的朋友，我一直认为那是非常甜蜜的。
And especially it's where in a weird way, you see Barney's most, like at his most vulnerable is when he's pleading for Ted to declare him his best friend.
尤其是在一个奇怪的地方，你看到巴尼最多的时候，就像他最脆弱的时候，他恳求泰德承认他是他最好的朋友。
He says it multiple times in the pilot.
他在试播集中多次说过这句话。
I'm your best friend, Sam, your best friend, and just like it's so, man, I'm proud of that launch of that character, because that's who he is.
我是你最好的朋友，山姆，你最好的朋友，就像这样，伙计，我为这个角色的推出感到自豪，因为这就是他。
He's vulnerable, he's a little broken, and he's needy, Ted is the planner getting way ahead of himself.
他很脆弱，他有点破碎，而且他很需要帮助，特德是一个超前的计划者。
Marshall and Lily just got engaged.
马歇尔和莉莉刚刚订婚。
Now it's my turn.
现在轮到我了。
That's the plan.
这就是计划。
The plan they got.
他们得到的计划。
They thread the needle in that.
他们把针穿进去了。
Now it's my turn.
现在轮到我了。
night.
夜晚。
And Marshall and Lily are this old married couple interacting with like, you know, their peers who seem 20 years younger than them.
马歇尔和莉莉是这对老夫妇，他们的同龄人看起来比他们年轻 20 岁。
It's so clear.
太清楚了。
There are kind of these three tracks going and the love and is this fourth track that gets added.
这三首曲目都在进行中，并且充满了爱，这是添加的第四首曲目。
I was very proud of the clarity of the thing.
我对事情的清晰性感到非常自豪。
And I wrote you this little ditty to sing to you in New York City.
我给你写了这首小曲，是为了在纽约唱给你听。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
Hey, Alex.
嘿，亚历克斯。
Josh, remember those legendary freezer pops from childhood summers?
乔什，还记得童年夏天那些传奇的冰柜汽水吗？
You know the one I'm talking about.
你知道我正在谈论的那个人。
The red, white, and blue ones.
有红的、白的、蓝的。
It is the only thing I remember from childhood.
这是我从小到大唯一记得的事情。
That's right.
这是正确的。
They pretty much ruled the neighborhood pools and playgrounds.
他们几乎统治着附近的游泳池和游乐场。
Your face should be covered with your finger.
你的脸应该用手指遮住。
It was just a delightful summer memory.
这只是一个愉快的夏日记忆。
Well, five hour energy has taken that iconic nostalgia and reimagined it as a bold, refreshing, firework-free's energy shot.
嗯，五小时能量消除了这种标志性的怀旧情绪，并将其重新想象为大胆、清爽、无烟花的能量镜头。
Every single sip delivers a massive flavor explosion, like the original pops of which you speak, expertly blending juicy cherry, citrusy lime, and sweet blue raspberry to completely ignite your taste buds.
每一口都会带来巨大的风味爆炸，就像您所说的原始流行音乐一样，巧妙地混合了多汁的樱桃、柑橘酸橙和甜美的蓝覆盆子，完全点燃您的味蕾。
It's that fruity taste that you crave, created with zero sugar, so you can enjoy the full experience, guilt-free.
这是您渴望的果香味道，采用零糖打造，让您可以无负罪感地享受完整的体验。
Whether you're conquering a packed schedule, tackling a mid-afternoon slump at your desk, headed out on a weekend road trip, or just looking to spark a vibrant new flavor sensation, this portable shot is the perfect daily companion.
无论您是要克服繁忙的日程、解决下午在办公桌前的困倦、周末公路旅行，还是只是想激发一种充满活力的新风味感觉，这款便携式镜头都是完美的日常伴侣。
Give your routine an exciting upgrade with a mouth-watering twist on a timeless favorite.
为您的日常生活带来令人兴奋的升级，为永恒的最爱带来令人垂涎的变化。
Ignite your taste buds with a firework freeze flavored five-hour energy shot, now available online at five-hourenergy.com or Amazon.
用烟花冷冻口味的五小时能量饮料点燃您的味蕾，现在可在 Five-hourenergy.com 或亚马逊上在线购买。
Alec, you know what happened to me when I found a good therapist?
亚历克，你知道当我找到一位好的治疗师后我发生了什么吗？
What happened to you when you found a good therapist?
当你找到一位好的治疗师后，你发生了什么？
I married her.
我娶了她。
Oh!
哦！
My wife Jordana is a therapist, a wonderful therapist, but today we're talking about RULA, which I believe Alec, you have used and can tell us a little more about.
我的妻子 Jordana 是一位治疗师，一位出色的治疗师，但今天我们谈论的是 RULA，我相信 Alec 您已经使用过它，并且可以告诉我们更多相关信息。
I can and I would like to announce first that I did not marry a single one of the therapists that I have used.
我可以而且我想首先宣布，我没有与我所使用的治疗师中的任何一位结婚。
It's good to say that right up front.
最好提前说清楚。
Disclaimer, yes, no rule is, it's fantastic.
免责声明，是的，没有规则，这太棒了。
It's a way of finding an online therapist, and I have used them for years.
这是寻找在线治疗师的一种方式，我已经使用它们很多年了。
It's basically built the way you would want a kind of website like this to be built.
它基本上是按照您想要的类似网站的方式构建的。
You go on and you get to tell a little bit about what you're looking for, and you get a list of therapists.
你继续下去，你可以告诉你一些你正在寻找的东西，然后你会得到一份治疗师名单。
And they could be anywhere, because this is entirely online, so you have a very large list.
它们可以在任何地方，因为这完全是在线的，所以你有一个非常大的列表。
And they'll tell you about themselves.
他们会告诉你关于他们自己的事情。
They have great bios of what brought them to this work, what interests them, what kind of work they've done in the past, what their techniques are, and you get to get a sense of who they are, which is completely different from, we just walk into a therapist's office.
他们有很好的简历，告诉他们是什么让他们从事这项工作，他们感兴趣什么，他们过去做过什么样的工作，他们的技术是什么，你可以了解他们是谁，这与我们走进治疗师的办公室完全不同。
You're just meeting this person for the first time.
你只是第一次见到这个人。
And what's really great about it is you can change.
它的真正伟大之处在于你可以改变。
You could change because the fit isn't quite right or just, actually just recently I changed because it had been a long time with one therapist and I just sort of had a sense that it was time to change and rule it makes it so easy.
你可以改变，因为不合适，或者只是，实际上最近我改变了，因为与一位治疗师在一起已经很长时间了，我只是有一种感觉，是时候改变了，规则让它变得如此简单。
You just go, you have your list of therapists and you can just choose whoever you feel is the right fit for you.
你只要走，你就有了治疗师名单，你可以选择你认为最适合你的人。
It almost sounds like Rula and I hope they're okay with me saying this.
这听起来几乎像鲁拉，我希望他们同意我这么说。
It's like a Somalia for therapists.
这就像治疗师的索马里。
It is.
这是。
It's exactly what it is.
就是这样。
You've got to start what you're looking for and they say, I have a lovely, I have a lovely person in Denver Colorado for you.
你必须开始你正在寻找的东西，他们说，我在科罗拉多州丹佛有一个可爱的人给你。
That's right and they give you just a little bit at you to take a little sip for at first.
没错，他们一开始只会给你一点点，让你喝一小口。
You just have your one appointment, see if it fits and if not, you send it back and you get that next bottle.
您只需进行一次预约，看看它是否合适，如果不合适，您将其寄回并获得下一瓶。
And I can attest as Alex's longtime friend.
作为亚历克斯的老朋友，我可以作证。
He used to be a mess and now he's all, he's doing great.
他曾经一团糟，现在他一切都好，他做得很好。
You knew me in the pre-Rula days, those were dark days.
你在鲁拉之前的日子里认识我，那是黑暗的日子。
I don't wish you pre-Rula on anyone.
我不希望你把鲁拉放在任何人身上。
But they've done great work with you.
但他们和你一起做了很棒的工作。
You're a shining example of what can happen.
你是可能发生的事情的光辉榜样。
Rula helps you find licensed therapists and psychiatrists who truly align with your background in goals Rather than just assigning you the first open slot available, even better, RULA RULA RULA works with over 100 major insurance plans nationwide, bringing the average session copay to just $15.
Rula 可以帮助您找到真正符合您目标背景的持证治疗师和精神科医生。 RULA RULA RULA 不仅为您分配第一个可用空位，更好的是，RULA RULA RULA 与全国 100 多个主要保险计划合作，使平均疗程自付额仅为 15 美元。
They support you from day one, tracking your milestones and helping you monitor your care along the way to ensure you are actually moving forward.
他们从第一天起就为您提供支持，跟踪您的里程碑并帮助您全程监控您的护理，以确保您真正取得进展。
Thousands of people are already using RULA to get affordable high quality therapy that's actually covered by insurance.
成千上万的人已经在使用 RULA 来获得负担得起的高质量治疗，而且这些治疗实际上是由保险承保的。
Visit RULA.com slash your mother to get started.
访问 RULA.com 砍掉你的母亲即可开始。
That's rula-ul-a.com slash your mother.
那是 rula-ul-a.com 砍你妈妈。
You deserve mental health care that works with you not against your budget.
您应该得到适合您的心理健康护理，而不是超出您的预算。
Snapple would like you to take a break from the sheds.
斯内普尔希望你能离开棚屋休息一下。
Those things you should be doing should be finishing should be thinking about.
那些你应该做、应该完成的事情、应该思考。
Well right now just uh crack open a snaple and just sit tight for a minute while Craig and I share some Snapple real facts with you Not unlike mr.
好吧，现在，呃，打开一个斯纳普，坐一会儿，克雷格和我与你分享一些斯纳普的真实事实，就像先生一样。
Mosby's fun facts mr.
莫斯比先生的有趣事实
Ted Mosby would have a lot of his fun facts We would love these and some of these are even an architecture related.
泰德·莫斯比 (Ted Mosby) 会有很多有趣的事实，我们会喜欢这些，其中一些甚至与建筑相关。
So give us our first fact What do you guys these all feel like things Ted or at least like a future like dad Ted would say All right, here is a Snapple Real Fact, 253.
那么，告诉我们第一个事实，你们这些人对泰德的事情有什么感觉，或者至少像泰德爸爸会说的那样的未来好吧，这是斯纳普真实的事实，253。
The first TV remote control introduced in 1950 was called Lazy Bones.
1950 年推出的第一个电视遥控器被称为“Lazy Bones”。
I didn't know that.
我不知道。
I mean, I mean, either.
我的意思是，我的意思是，要么。
Real Fact, 1517, in New York, it is illegal to sell a haunted house without telling the buyer.
真实事实，1517年，在纽约，在不通知买家的情况下出售鬼屋是违法的。
That's actually amazing.
这实际上是惊人的。
And that feels like a very, that feels like a very martial actually.
这感觉就像是一种非常非常武术的感觉。
These are weirdly resonant.
这些产生了奇怪的共鸣。
Okay, in fact, that is amazing and I want to know more, but we don't have time for it in the snaple chat.
好吧，事实上，这太棒了，我想了解更多，但我们没有时间在 snaple 聊天中了解它。
Real facts, 1978, 1,978 I'm gonna think has nothing to do with the year 1978.
真实的事实，1978 年，1,978 我认为与 1978 年无关。
More than 40 buildings in New York have their own zip codes.
纽约有 40 多座建筑物都有自己的邮政编码。
That is totally a Ted Mosby fund.
这完全是泰德·莫斯比基金。
He would actually know that.
他实际上会知道这一点。
He told every girl from that.
他告诉每个女孩。
Snaple real fact, 1,667.
斯内普真实事实，1,667。
Lovebirds are actual birds.
爱情鸟是真正的鸟类。
Boom, and we bring you back to love.
繁荣，我们让你重拾爱情。
It's all full circle.
这都是完整的循环。
It's all very him, yeah me.
这一切都是他的，是的，我的。
All right, that's your rig.
好吧，这就是你的装备。
Quick fun and just a little unexpected.
快速有趣，只是有点出乎意料。
Next time you hit pause and make a count with Snapple on your next break.
下次您按下暂停按钮并在下一次休息时使用 Snapple 进行计数。
And now, back's the show.
现在，节目又回来了。
Also, it's funny when you consider the origin story of each character, which then what episode, what season was how we met everyone else or how I met everyone else?
另外，当你考虑每个角色的起源故事时，这很有趣，那么在哪一集，哪一季我们是如何认识其他人的，或者我是如何认识其他人的？
How we met everyone else is season three episode five.
我们如何认识其他人是第三季第五集。
That's a great episode.
这是一个很棒的插曲。
And what's funny to me is like, well, Ted and Marshall were freshman roommates.
对我来说有趣的是，泰德和马歇尔是新生室友。
That's like a very clear, yeah, kind of, not obvious, but it's a way one meets a good friend, possibly, or an enemy.
这就像一个非常明确的，是的，有点，不明显，但这是一个人结识好朋友，可能，或敌人的一种方式。
Yeah.
是的。
Bernie started talking to Ted at a urinal at a bar and then slides into a booth and starts trying to change his whole style.
伯尼开始在酒吧的小便池里和泰德交谈，然后溜进一个隔间，开始尝试改变他的整体风格。
Like it's a very strange, he just muscles his way into this guy's life.
就像很奇怪一样，他只是用武力闯入了这个家伙的生活。
He's like, it's so aggressive.
他就像，这太有侵略性了。
We're gonna be friends now.
我们现在要成为朋友了。
I'm going to change how you dress and how you approach women.
我将改变你的着装和对待女性的方式。
And I just think he saw him as a project, but more than that, he was like, I want to roll with this guy.
我只是认为他把他视为一个项目，但更重要的是，他说，我想和这个家伙一起工作。
Like, I thought there was something lovely and weird about like, why was everyone always fighting over Ted?
就像，我觉得有一些可爱又奇怪的东西，比如为什么每个人总是为了特德而争吵？
Like they wanted it.
就像他们想要的那样。
They wanted to be close to this guy, which I always liked.
他们想靠近这个人，这是我一直喜欢的。
I love it.
我喜欢它。
And you feel it.
你感觉到了。
Right away in the, in the pile and you feel the angel side and the double side, both want Ted.
马上就在堆里，你感觉到天使的一面和双重的一面，都想要特德。
Yeah.
是的。
I mean, you did that.
我的意思是，你做到了。
You did that.
你做到了。
You did that joke on Halloween literally, right?
你确实在万圣节开过这个玩笑，对吗？
That's the devil.
那就是魔鬼。
Yeah, we did that because we said, let's make literal how we pitch the show.
是的，我们这样做是因为我们说过，让我们按照字面意思来宣传节目。
I like that because it's really how we pitch the show.
我喜欢这样，因为这确实是我们推销节目的方式。
We said, you know, because there was, my wife and I were kind of like Marshall and Lily.
我们说，你知道，因为我和我的妻子有点像马歇尔和莉莉。
We in Carter, all went to college together.
我们卡特一起上大学。
We met in college.
我们是在大学认识的。
And then I was in New York City in our 20s.
然后我二十多岁就到了纽约。
And Carter was like the single guy going out and having fun and like the being out until three in the morning.
卡特就像一个出去玩的单身汉，喜欢一直出去到凌晨三点。
And I was like, sometimes it like a bed and breakfast upstate and upstate New York in my 20s with like people in their 60s like playing Scrabble.
我当时想，有时它就像纽约州北部和纽约州北部的一家住宿加早餐酒店，20 多岁的我和喜欢玩拼字游戏的 60 多岁的人一样。
And every now and again, we were like, This is where we're getting old.
时不时地，我们会想，这就是我们变老的地方。
We're making ourselves really old, really fast.
我们正在让自己变老，变老的速度非常快。
And that just seemed funny.
这看起来很有趣。
And I would suddenly, I'd be getting my calls and texts and stuff from these guys, these late showwriters that we're all out having these legendary nights and then be like, every now and again, I'd be like, ah, I kind of want to show us out there.
突然间，我会接到这些家伙、这些已故编剧的电话和短信之类的东西，我们都在外面度过了这些传奇的夜晚，然后我时不时地会想，啊，我有点想带我们去那里。
I mean, we played that with Marshall a little bit.
我的意思是，我们和马歇尔一起玩过一点。
And but Ted wants to be where, Ted wants to be doing scrabble at the button breakfast.
但泰德想去哪里，泰德想在按钮早餐时玩拼字游戏。
It's just a funny dynamic.
这只是一个有趣的动态。
And it feels like that's immediately there.
感觉就像立刻就在那里。
Marshall and Lily want Ted to find that woman.
马歇尔和莉莉希望泰德找到那个女人。
We did a whole episode about that, the front porch test, right?
我们为此做了一整集，前廊测试，对吧？
We want to be growing old on a front porch playing Scrabble Drink and Lemonade.
我们想在前廊上玩拼字游戏、饮料和柠檬水，慢慢变老。
Yeah.
是的。
On the front porch with Ted and whoever, this TBD woman's going to be, but Barney wants to do everything to keep that from happening.
与泰德和其他人一起在前廊上，这个待定的女人将会出现，但巴尼想尽一切努力阻止这种情况发生。
There's also a lot about in the pilot especially, but kind of really baked into the show is how old you are and what's almost like appropriate for you to be doing at what age.
特别是在试播集中，还有很多内容，但真正融入到这部剧的是你的年龄以及适合你在什么年龄做的事情。
Like Ted is obsessed in the pilot that he's 27 and they weren't supposed to get engaged until they were 30.
就像泰德痴迷于试播集一样，他已经 27 岁了，而他们不应该在 30 岁之前订婚。
It's like this arbitrary thing like no one getting engaged on the street and Marshall throws the whole plan off.
这就像一件任意的事情，就像没有人在街上订婚一样，马歇尔放弃了整个计划。
And then it throws Ted into an existential crisis.
然后它让特德陷入了生存危机。
And yeah, but even you know, sometimes getting out over your skis in terms of like, you don't want to be at the bed in breakfast playing Scrapple.
是的，但即使你知道，有时你也不想在早餐时在床上玩 Scrapple 游戏。
Like that's going to happen soon enough.
好像这很快就会发生。
Like don't rush it.
就像不要着急一样。
I think there's something Ted has such a like a motor on his life that is going and he's like he's worried he's falling far behind, which is kind of hilarious to think about nowadays like a 27 year old single guy in New York City freaking out about that.
我认为 Ted 的生活中有一种动力在运转，他担心自己远远落后，现在想想，就像纽约市一个 27 岁的单身汉为此感到惊慌一样，这有点搞笑。
Like I think it was a little weird then, but it's even weirder now.
我觉得当时有点奇怪，但现在更奇怪了。
It's so weird.
太奇怪了。
It's so weird being like we're basically like 50 and like looking at this 27 year old being like, I got it all planned out and like I got away till I'm the 30 and like Jesus do and it never mind the fact that you also looked like such kids all of you.
这太奇怪了，我们基本上都50岁了，看着这个27岁的人，我把这一切都计划好了，就像我离开直到我30岁，就像耶稣所做的那样，没关系，你们看起来也像这样的孩子。
It's so great.
太棒了。
Which might be also just off camera.
这也可能就在镜头外。
We looked like children as well, Carter and I and it was I mean, what did it feel like to you to look back and see pilot you and be sort of assessing it through now, through these eyes and just be looking at this, did it bring you back to that moment and be like, this was a different me.
我们看起来也像孩子，卡特和我，我的意思是，当你回头看，看到你正在驾驶，并通过这些眼睛来评估它时，你有什么感觉，只是看着这个，它是否让你回到了那一刻，就像，这是一个不同的我。
You know, it did.
你知道，确实如此。
Oh, I mean, one I haven't, I've had a beard for so long, it was like weird to see my face.
哦，我是说，我没有，我留胡子这么久了，看到我的脸感觉很奇怪。
I remember that guy, like I remember that guy, he doesn't exactly feel like me or he feels like a some weird avatar of me or some iteration of me that is not quite around.
我记得那个人，就像我记得那个人一样，他并不完全像我，或者他感觉像是我的某个奇怪的化身，或者是我的某个不完全存在的迭代。
But I was struck and I say this very delicately and I don't want this to come off as self-agronizing like I was aware as the show went on that there was a lot of love for Ted but there was also like a lot of...
但我很震惊，我非常微妙地说这句话，我不想让这件事显得自我贬低，就像我在节目进行时意识到的那样，人们对特德有很多爱，但也有很多……
there were some haters, right?
有一些仇恨者，对吗？
And I was new to fame.
我刚刚成名。
I was new to being seen every week in people's homes.
我对每周都会出现在人们家中感到陌生。
And I'm a sensitive person.
而且我是一个敏感的人。
I'm pretty thin skinned.
我脸皮还蛮薄的
I don't think I'm alone in that.
我不认为我是唯一一个这样做的人。
Getting trolled or getting...
被恶搞或被...
I didn't get abused in some sort of epic way.
我没有受到某种史诗般的虐待。
But I think I went through the series feeling I know what I'm good at here.
但我想我在看完这个系列后感觉我知道自己擅长什么。
I also know that sometimes Ted's eccentricities annoy people or whatever.
我还知道有时特德的怪癖会惹恼别人或其他什么。
But I watched the pilot and I was struck by the fact that I thought I was really good in it.
但当我观看了试播集后，我被一个事实震惊了：我认为自己真的很擅长。
And I hope it's okay to say that.
我希望这样说是可以的。
You were.
你是。
I thought there was a job to do with this guy.
我以为这个家伙有工作要做。
That was that was kind of a high level of difficulty, right?
那就是难度很高吧？
To be like very high.
变得非常高。
The kind of engaging center, charming center of this show, to be the eyes and ears for the audience, but also to be passionate and lovesick and forward moving.
这个节目的那种引人入胜、迷人的中心，既要成为观众的耳目，又要激情相思、前行。
It was a big ask, and I thought, you know what?
这是一个很大的问题，我想，你知道吗？
You did a good job.
你做得很好。
It was almost like telling a younger part of me, but you were really hard on yourself.
这几乎就像是在讲述我年轻的一面，但你对自己真的很苛刻。
You did a great job.
你做得很好。
See, this is what this podcast is a little bit.
看，这就是这个播客的一点点。
I hope people can hear that and think about that, really think about that, that it's taken on 20 years for you to look back and say that.
我希望人们能够听到并思考这一点，真正思考一下，你花了 20 年的时间才回顾并说出这句话。
It's almost like most high schoolers are pretty insecure, and most high schoolers are kind of looking at themselves and you know three years earlier you looked like a totally different person and you're adapting to this new body and this new voice and new new body hair and like your body is changing for everyone and and it's a very startling experience and then you look back on pictures and you're like you know we were pretty like attractive young kids like we were really hard on ourselves right yeah yeah yeah that's how I felt watching the pilot like man and I'm so hard on myself.
这几乎就像大多数高中生都非常没有安全感，大多数高中生都在审视自己，你知道三年前你看起来完全不同了，你正在适应这个新的身体，这个新的声音和新的体毛，就像你的身体正在为每个人改变，这是一个非常惊人的经历，然后你回顾照片，你就像你知道我们很像有吸引力的年轻孩子，就像我们对自己真的很严格，是的，是的，这就是我看飞行员的感觉人和我对自己太严格了。
I looked fine.
我看起来很好。
I looked like a guy who belonged, you know, I looked like a guy who belonged on the TV, you know.
我看起来像一个属于的人，你知道，我看起来像一个属于电视的人，你知道。
I felt like you were so self-besured in the role, and very, very confident.
我觉得你对这个角色非常自信，而且非常非常自信。
I mean, some of that was also the Ted's high status in that pilot.
我的意思是，其中一部分也是泰德在该飞行员中的崇高地位。
Everyone wants what's best for Ted.
每个人都想给特德最好的。
Everyone wants to think you guys wrote in, and we're gonna unpack this like ad nauseam, so I don't wanna get too much into it.
每个人都想认为是你们写的，我们会像令人作呕一样解开这个包，所以我不想过多地讨论它。
But you wrote in some, one of the things that I struggled with the first season, and I remember talking to you in Carter about this, is there'd be an episode like Drumroll, please, where Ted was absolutely the hero.
但你在一些书中写到，我在第一季中遇到的困难之一，我记得在《卡特》中与你谈论过这一点，是否会有像《鼓声》这样的一集，其中泰德绝对是英雄。
He was the romantic hero, and he was held up and almost shot in a heroic way.
他是浪漫的英雄，他被人举起，差点被枪杀，表现得很英勇。
And you were supposed to be rooting for him.
你应该支持他。
The very next episode, I think it was like, he made like the mixtape for Ashley, maybe, something like it was something so silly.
就在下一集，我认为就像是，他为阿什利制作了混音带，也许，类似的事情太愚蠢了。
And it was like I could tell that there was an invitation then to make fun of him.
就好像我可以看出有人邀请我来取笑他。
Right.
正确的。
And I remember saying to you guys, I'm getting whiplash going from like, I'm a hero to I'm a ridiculous person to be ridiculed.
我记得我对你们说过，我正在从“我是英雄”变成“我是一个可笑的、值得嘲笑的人”。
So it's a thing I want to talk about.
所以这是我想谈的一件事。
It's a thing I want to talk about.
这是我想谈的一件事。
Yeah, I mean, I'm not saying I wanted to play like Jack Bauer or someone who was just always a hero of the same job.
是的，我的意思是，我并不是说我想像杰克·鲍尔（Jack Bauer）或始终是同一工作的英雄那样打球。
That's what I'm saying.
这就是我所说的。
But I do feel in the pilot, even though Ted has his foibles, he has the kind of heroes journey, momentum.
但我确实在试播集中感受到，尽管特德有他的缺点，但他有英雄之旅的那种动力。
You're rooting for him, which I did find we can talk about this in a second, but I was so into him being with Robin when he goes up in the suit.
你支持他，我确实发现我们可以稍后讨论这个问题，但当他穿上西装时，我非常喜欢他和罗宾在一起。
And it's really quite sexy for prime time, just in terms of like the way they're looking at each other.
在黄金时段，这真的很性感，就像他们互相看对方的方式一样。
Yeah.
是的。
There's real bad news.
确实有坏消息。
And there's real like, and the moment he's, I knew it was coming, but the moment he says I think I'm in love with you, I almost was like, like, Barney Marshall and Lily, like, what?
真的很像，当他出现的那一刻，我知道它即将到来，但当他说我想我爱上你的那一刻，我几乎就像，就像，巴尼·马歇尔和莉莉，就像，什么？
Like, it was such a bad move.
就像，这是一个糟糕的举动。
And of course, it sets off the entire series, so it needed to happen.
当然，它引发了整个系列，所以它需要发生。
But it was such an ill-timed, ill-informed move.
但这是一个不合时宜、不明智的举动。
So I was actually crushed by that in a way that I was like, okay, this pilot's working.
所以我真的被这件事压垮了，我想，好吧，这个飞行员正在工作。
Like if you're mad at him for ruining that.
就像你因为他破坏了这一切而生他的气一样。
I think the show kind of called it shots so early to not just be like, this is the, it all makes sense half hour.
我认为这部剧这么早就决定了，不仅仅是这样，这就是，这半个小时都是有意义的。
It's like the other things at eight, the show, right before us on CBS and the show right after us are that and the show after that, all the other shows were that because they were where these sort of like goes down easy kind of like simple comedies.
就像八点钟的其他节目一样，哥伦比亚广播公司（CBS）在我们之前的节目、我们之后的节目以及之后的节目，所有其他节目都是这样，因为它们是这些节目很容易上演的地方，就像简单的喜剧一样。
And that was what that's the thing that's so hard to explain to people, because we were this weird black sheep on that network, but that was the other thing that was proud of in that pilot.
这就是很难向人们解释的事情，因为我们是该网络上这只奇怪的害群之马，但这是该试点项目中值得自豪的另一件事。
We called our shot like that moment, Josh, where he says, I love you.
我们就在那一刻决定了我们的决定，乔什，他说，我爱你。
And you cut to, you time jump to three different timelines of people saying, what, you jump to, you have Robyn say what?
然后你切到，你的时间跳到三个不同的时间线，人们说，什么，你跳到，你让罗宾说什么？
You jump to the future kids 25 years in the future saying what?
你跳到25年后的未来孩子们说什么？
And you also jumped to the future group, all saying what, right?
而你也跳到了未来组，都说啥是吧？
Being told the story, like being told the story of that later.
被讲述这个故事，就像后来被讲述这个故事一样。
And that's boom, boom, boom.
那就是繁荣、繁荣、繁荣。
In like 10 seconds, there's three timelines, one of which is literally 25 years in the future.
在大约 10 秒的时间内，出现了三个时间线，其中之一实际上是 25 年后的未来。
Yeah.
是的。
And I, that was like, maybe my favorite moment rewatching a pilot.
而我，这也许是我最喜欢重看飞行员的时刻。
Cause that was like, yeah, it's so jarring.
因为那就像，是的，这太不和谐了。
And I remember having, I don't know if you remember this, but we would, we, we had notes and concerns on that moment from the studio network.
我记得，我不知道你是否记得这一点，但我们会，我们，我们从工作室网络那里得到了关于那一刻的笔记和担忧。
They were like, is that just too confusing?
他们说，这太令人困惑了吗？
because the one that was deemed most confusing was jumping ahead of the bar.
因为被认为最令人困惑的是跳到酒吧前面。
You know what I mean later?
稍后你知道我的意思吗？
And it's the gang saying what?
那帮人在说什么？
Because there were like, do people's, are people's brains going to catch up to that idea that we're jumping to there?
因为人们的大脑会跟上我们跳到那里的想法吗？
They're talking about it in the future.
他们正在谈论未来。
It's my favorite quote about filmmaking from Billy Wilder.
这是我最喜欢的比利·怀尔德关于电影制作的名言。
He says, let the audience put two and two together in the love you forever.
他说，让观众把两个两个放在一起永远爱你。
Yes.
是的。
And that's, that is what that pilot did at a few key spots.
这就是飞行员在几个关键地点所做的事情。
So the, I love you spot.
所以，我爱你。
Ted has, has been the hero.
特德一直是英雄。
He's having his hero's moment.
他正在经历英雄时刻。
And he absolutely fucks it up in an incredibly jarring, like, like, uh, nails on a chalkboard in cringy way.
他绝对以一种令人难以置信的不和谐的方式搞砸了，就像，呃，以令人难堪的方式在黑板上钉钉子。
But even made you, you yourself 20, something years later, go, no, and scream at the TV.
但即使是让你，几年后20岁的你，走开，不，对着电视尖叫。
I think he texted me that and I'd be like, I'm yelling a tad on the TV right now with Trinana.
我想他给我发了短信，我会想，我现在正在电视上和特里纳娜一起大喊大叫。
Uh, and yet that, that spurs you into that great little boom, boom, boom, three different timelines.
呃，然而，这会刺激你进入那个伟大的小繁荣，繁荣，繁荣，三个不同的时间线。
Jump, jump, jump.
跳，跳，跳。
And that was the show saying this is what the, this is who we are.
那个节目说这就是我们，这就是我们。
Yeah.
是的。
But pilot is challenging because you have to teach the audience how to watch it.
但试播集是有挑战性的，因为你必须教观众如何观看。
And especially if it's a show that is as narratively complex is how I made your mother you you had to do a lot of like Training of your audience to watch the show and that was our argument to keep it We said let's keep it because this will show people that we're gonna be jumping around all the time It'll it'll keep you on your toes.
特别是如果这是一个叙事复杂的节目，就像我如何让你的母亲成为你一样，你必须做很多事情，比如训练你的观众观看节目，这是我们保留它的理由，我们说让我们保留它，因为这会向人们表明我们将一直跳来跳去，它会让你保持警惕。
This is not like lie back on the couch looking at your phone watching This is like pay a little bit of attention here And it's to their credit the student networks had great keep it.
这不像躺在沙发上看手机，这就像在这里稍微注意一下，值得赞扬的是，学生网络很好地保持了这一点。
Yeah, it's less.
是啊，少了。
I did want to go back to one thing you said about we're not the tidy resolution show.
我确实想回到你所说的一件事，即我们不是整洁的解决方案节目。
I wonder if some of the ferocious dedication to the show is almost like that friend you have that tells you the truth.
我想知道对这部剧的一些狂热奉献是否就像你的那个告诉你真相的朋友一样。
Yeah.
是的。
It's like you're closer to the person who will say the thing or say the thing because they love you.
就好像你和那个会说这句话的人更亲近，或者说那句话是因为他们爱你。
Yeah.
是的。
That's my friend John.
那是我的朋友约翰。
John Marrow who shout out to John who did our art for or how he made your mother and he does all my art.
约翰·马罗（John Marrow）向约翰大声喊道，约翰为我们创作了艺术，或者他如何创造了你的母亲，他创作了我所有的艺术。
But he said to me one year, a year ago, and I don't think I'll mind me saying this, but he said, hey, you've known me for a long time now, like, where are my blind spots?
但他一年前对我说，我不认为我会介意我这么说，但他说，嘿，你已经认识我很长时间了，比如，我的盲点在哪里？
Like, what am I missing as a person in my life?
比如，作为一个人，我的生活中缺少什么？
And he really wanted that feedback.
他真的很想要这种反馈。
And then I asked for it back, you know, just because I really trust him.
然后我要求归还，你知道，只是因为我真的信任他。
And it was all said with a lot of love.
这一切都是充满爱意的。
But there was a, this author, Sahil Bloom, who I've become friends with, he has a book out called The Five Types of Wealth.
但有一位作家，萨希尔·布鲁姆（Sahil Bloom），我和他成为了朋友，他出版了一本书，名叫《财富的五种类型》。
And Jordan and I went to hear him at the 92nd Street Y, Susan Kane interviewed him last night.
乔丹和我去第 92 街 Y 听他讲话，苏珊·凯恩昨晚采访了他。
It was a really wonderful evening.
这真是一个美好的夜晚。
But he said this really great thing.
但他说这真是伟大的事情。
He said, if your life is a movie, what is the audience shouting at you that you're not getting?
他说，如果你的人生是一部电影，观众对你大喊大叫而你却看不到的是什么？
You know, it's like, he loves you, you idiot, like, don't say I love you on the first day of Ted.
你知道，就像，他爱你，你这个白痴，就像，不要在特德的第一天说我爱你。
But it was funny because that's the energy of, you know, I was doing what you were having the, you were having characters at various times, due to the thing that the audience would do, which is like, wait, what, you know, yeah, absolutely, absolutely.
但这很有趣，因为这就是能量，你知道，我正在做你所拥有的事情，你在不同的时间拥有角色，由于观众会做的事情，就像，等等，什么，你知道，是的，绝对，绝对。
And that what, what, what was also our way of acknowledging that like, we're asking the audience to go along with something here that they're going to be yelling about.
那什么、什么、什么也是我们承认这一点的方式，我们要求观众同意他们会大喊大叫的东西。
So we need people yelling literally throughout 25, was 25 years of yelling at 10.
所以我们需要人们在 25 岁的时候大喊大叫，也就是 25 年在 10 岁的时候大喊大叫。
So I was like saying, look, we're two.
所以我想说，看，我们是两个人。
We were outraged because we made your we wrote.
我们很愤怒，因为我们写了你的文章。
People are still going to be yelling at this in the year 2030.
到了 2030 年，人们仍然会对此大喊大叫。
The kids yelling at him.
孩子们对他大喊大叫。
Yeah, it's an iconic thing.
是的，这是一个标志性的事情。
Let me just ask a question from the internet about that.
让我从互联网上问一个问题。
We've got a lot of questions that have come in and please send them everywhere that you send questions.
我们收到了很多问题，请将它们发送到您发送问题的任何地方。
But we're all over online on our website on Instagram and H Shane One oh three asks you was it difficult to first get into playing Ted or did you relate to the character and did that make it easy to do so well you're looking back on this this this character that again is so positive so forward thinking were you that at 27 and how do those two connect.
但是我们在 Instagram 网站上到处都是，H Shane One oh Three 询问你第一次扮演 Ted 是否很困难，或者你是否与这个角色有联系，并且这是否让你很容易做得这么好，你回顾这个这个角色，再次如此积极，所以前瞻性的思考是你在 27 岁，以及这两个角色如何联系起来。
Yeah, I mean I was what 30 31 when we did the pilot I can't remember but so I'm three four years older than Ted.
是的，我的意思是，当我们拍摄试播集时，我记不清了，我是 30 31 岁，但我比特德大三四岁。
I always felt like I was playing someone younger than me, so it was almost like my little brother that I've described him as my little brother that I love dearly, but sometimes wanted to smack around and tell him to snap out of it.
我总觉得我在扮演一个比我年轻的人，所以这几乎就像我的弟弟一样，我把他描述为我深爱的弟弟，但有时又想拍打他，让他振作起来。
I've never used that way, but that's a fantastic description.
我从来没有用过这种方式，但这是一个很棒的描述。
I think I shared some of Ted's ambition and pluck.
我想我也有特德的一些野心和勇气。
I do think at that time I was much more, I wouldn't say I was more optimistic.
我确实认为当时我要乐观得多，我不会说我更加乐观。
There's a term called spiritual bypassing.
有一个词叫精神绕行。
I don't know if you guys have ever heard that, but it's basically like always kind of moving through and looking at the bright side and it's a very shadow denying kind of posture.
我不知道你们是否听说过，但这基本上就像总是穿过并看到光明的一面，这是一种非常否认阴影的姿势。
And I think in some ways in this is like Ted, like I hadn't, throughout the course of of the run throughout my 30s, I needed more life.
我认为在某种程度上，这就像特德一样，就像我没有一样，在我 30 多岁的跑步过程中，我需要更多的生活。
I needed more suffering.
我需要更多的痛苦。
I needed more failure.
我需要更多的失败。
I needed, you know, when I had failures along the way, I got fired from my first pilot, which I've talked about, like I need, but there's something about you want, you get seasoned, life seasons you, you know?
我需要，你知道，当我一路上遇到失败时，我被我的第一个飞行员解雇了，我已经谈论过，就像我需要的那样，但是你想要一些东西，你变得经验丰富，生活让你成熟，你知道吗？
And I don't think we have to engineer stress and strain and set back and stumble for people.
我认为我们不必制造压力和紧张，并为人们带来挫折和绊脚石。
Life does that, right?
生活就是这样，对吗？
Yes.
是的。
But I think I had some naivete a little bit.
但我觉得我还是有点天真。
I think I didn't quite understand what it was.
我想我不太明白那是什么。
I think if I had a little more confidence in the pilot than I did maybe later, and I know I regained it at some level or at some point.
我想如果我对飞行员比以前更有信心，也许以后会更好，而且我知道我在某种程度上或在某个时刻重新获得了它。
But there was something I was so such a driven young actor.
但有一点我是一个如此有动力的年轻演员。
I really knew this was a big opportunity.
我真的知道这是一个很大的机会。
I really wanted to seize it.
我真的很想抓住它。
But I lived in New York City.
但我住在纽约市。
I drank a lot of beer at bars.
我在酒吧喝了很多啤酒。
I got scared to talk to women and some nights it worked and some nights it didn't work.
我害怕和女人说话，有些晚上它有效，有些晚上它不起作用。
I went to a small liberal arts college.
我去了一所小型文理学院。
I was from Ohio.
我来自俄亥俄州。
There were a lot of biographical things that lined up, but I also think I had, I constitutionally, I think, have, I don't know what it is.
有很多传记性的东西排列在一起，但我也认为我有，我认为，我本质上有，我不知道那是什么。
I went on a very spiritual journey when I was in my 30s on, you know, off screen.
当我三十多岁的时候，你知道，在银幕之外，我经历了一次非常精神的旅程。
And I was really trying to ask myself some big questions because I think what happens to me, and this is something we could talk about later, but like when you have success, you get to the kind of top of that mountain.
我真的很想问自己一些大问题，因为我想我会发生什么，这是我们稍后可以讨论的事情，但就像当你取得成功时，你就会到达山顶。
It's the thing of like you climb to the top of the ladder and realize maybe it was propped against the wrong wall.
这就像你爬到梯子的顶部，然后意识到它可能靠在错误的墙上。
You know, like, is this, is this what I want?
你知道，就像，这就是我想要的吗？
Is this what I'm looking for?
这就是我要找的吗？
And so I really started to ask myself some big questions about, is this enough?
所以我真的开始问自己一些大问题，这足够了吗？
You know, what do I really want to be doing?
你知道，我真正想做的是什么？
And maybe those are, you know, not unmosby-ish, but I think I appreciated his energy and his passion and his optimism and his resilience.
你知道，也许这些并不是unmosby-ish，但我想我很欣赏他的精力、他的热情、他的乐观和他的韧性。
I mean, that would be the biggest thing that I would almost like to learn from him and honor about him was, man, that guy got kicked down and just came back.
我的意思是，这将是我想从他身上学到的最重要的事情，对他的荣誉是，伙计，那个家伙被踢倒了，然后又回来了。
He came back.
他回来了。
And that's a great word.
这是一个很棒的词。
That's the word.
就是这个词。
Resilience and vulnerability, you know, he was not afraid to say how he was feeling.
坚韧和脆弱，你知道，他并不害怕说出自己的感受。
He was not afraid to, well, that's the thing.
他并不害怕，嗯，就是这样。
I think heroic qualities for a man.
我认为男人的英雄品质。
I agree, and I don't think you were seeing that in comedies.
我同意，而且我认为你不会在喜剧中看到这一点。
You weren't seeing a man sensitive.
你没有看到一个敏感的男人。
The speech Ted Gibbs after fucking up, after, say, blurting out, I love you up in Robbins.
泰德·吉布斯在搞砸之后的演讲，在罗宾斯脱口而出“我爱你”之后。
You don't get that amazing speech from Ted and so wonderfully acted and performed by you out there.
你不会听到特德那令人惊叹的演讲，也不会看到你的精彩表演。
I mean, that is just a home run.
我的意思是，这只是一个本垒打。
I was like tears in my eyes rewatching that, but in part just because of how good it was And in part, just remembering being there that night, watching you do it on that street at the CBS Radford lot, that was not where we shot how I met your mother after the pilot.
重温时我眼里含着泪水，但部分是因为它有多精彩，部分是因为我记得那天晚上在那里，看着你在哥伦比亚广播公司雷德福停车场的那条街上做这件事，那不是我们拍摄试播集后我遇见你母亲的场景的地方。
We shot the pilot in the valley of the CBS lot, and then shot every other episode basically at the Fox lot in West LA, so it was completely different.
我们在哥伦比亚广播公司的山谷里拍摄了试播集，然后基本上在西洛杉矶的福克斯电视台拍摄了其他每一集，所以这是完全不同的。
But for the pilot, for CBS, it's where we had the space and the money sent us there at that moment.
但对于哥伦比亚广播公司的试播集来说，这是我们当时拥有空间和资金的地方。
And I had this memory, Josh, of you out there in the magic of that night, and it was a night shoot on this fake New York City street, but it looked beautiful.
乔什，我有这样的记忆，那天晚上你在神奇的地方，那是在纽约市这条假街道上拍摄的夜景，但它看起来很漂亮。
It was all lit up, all pretty.
一切都亮起来了，一切都很漂亮。
There was that thing where they kind of went down the sidewalks, like listening and shiny and magical.
他们走在人行道上，就像倾听一样，闪亮而神奇。
And just watching you there, it's like I stepped into that TV now from the year 2025 back into 2005.
光是看着你，就好像我从 2025 年走进了那台电视，回到了 2005 年。
And I felt I was there with young you and young me and I had this unbelievable wave of nostalgia that I was like, overcome by.
我觉得我和年轻的你和年轻的我在一起，我有一种难以置信的怀旧浪潮，我被它征服了。
And I was like, I wanted to go be with them.
我当时想，我想和他们在一起。
I wanted to go be there.
我想去那里。
I wanted to feel what they felt.
我想感受他们的感受。
There was like this drumming aliveness I felt of like, yes, we were like in our late 20s or 30, we were 30, I think.
我感觉就像是这种鼓点般的活力，是的，我们就像二十多岁或三十岁，我想我们已经三十岁了。
And there we were, this was our first big shot.
就这样，这是我们的第一个大人物。
We were all like vibing and aligned and connected.
我们都像振动一样，一致且紧密相连。
We knew what we were doing.
我们知道我们在做什么。
I remember watching you do that speech, which again, is so brilliantly performed, brilliantly written.
我记得看过你做那次演讲，演讲再次表现得非常出色，写得也非常出色。
I give Carter so much, like Carter really wrote, he wrote that speech so beautifully.
我给了卡特很多，就像卡特真正写的那样，他的演讲写得非常漂亮。
I feel like that's such a Carter, that was really Carter connecting with Ted, I think.
我觉得这就是卡特，我认为那真的是卡特与特德的联系。
Because a Carter was single.
因为卡特是单身。
Carter was saying how he felt, he wanted, he wanted to do everything Ted said in that speech is where Carter wanted to be.
卡特说的是他的感受，他想要，他想要做特德在演讲中所说的一切，这就是卡特想要的。
It was his same aspiration.
这也是他同样的愿望。
And it's very vulnerable to write that.
而且这样写很容易受到攻击。
and you just performed it with such vulnerability, but also this kind of heroism.
你只是表现得如此脆弱，但也有这种英雄主义。
You forget all about how much Ted fucked up two seconds ago, saying I love you up in the apartment, because now he's your hero, and he's so emotionally articulate and intelligent in that speech that I think he wins you over, and you don't get that speech unless Ted fucked up upstairs.
你完全忘记了特德两秒钟前在公寓里搞砸了多少，说我爱你在公寓里，因为现在他是你的英雄，他在那次演讲中情绪表达清晰且聪明，我认为他赢得了你的支持，除非特德在楼上搞砸了，否则你不会得到那个演讲。
So Ted has to be the guy who can fuck up upstairs and has to be the guy that absolutely sweeps you off your feet by acknowledging the fuck up and then surprising you with this unbelievable sentiment that you did not see coming in that moment.
所以特德必须是那个可以在楼上搞砸的人，并且必须是那个让你彻底震惊的人，他承认搞砸了，然后用你在那一刻没有预见到的令人难以置信的情绪让你感到惊讶。
So I mean, it works.
所以我的意思是，它有效。
Yeah, it works so well because Robin gave him the look.
是的，它非常有效，因为罗宾给了他这样的表情。
She gave him the look.
她看了他一眼。
And this old man, he must have me, fell in love with you, New York City.
而这个老人，他一定是有我，爱上了你，纽约市。
And now, commercials.
现在，广告。
Hey Craig, you know now that I have a child, a baby in the house, you know what I'm finding it hard to do?
嘿克雷格，你现在知道我有一个孩子了，家里有一个婴儿，你知道我觉得做什么很难吗？
What?
什么？
To remember to do?
要记得做什么？
What's that?
那是什么？
Eat food.
吃食物。
It's one of the basic needs that is no longer the priority.
这是基本需求之一，但不再是优先事项。
I know, and I forget.
我知道，但我忘记了。
It's like, oh, I forgot to feed Nelson, my dog, and myself.
就像，哦，我忘了喂尼尔森、我的狗和我自己。
So how are we going to solve that problem?
那么我们要如何解决这个问题呢？
Well, I just need something just quick on the go that I won't, no must, no fuss.
好吧，我只是需要一些快速的东西，我不会，没有必要，不用大惊小怪。
I just need to feed myself and get some energy so I can get back to parenting.
我只需要养活自己并获得一些能量，这样我就可以回去养育孩子了。
Yes, and so what would solve that problem?
是的，那么什么可以解决这个问题呢？
I'm going to steer you towards an outcome and the outcome is this product you're about to mention.
我将引导您走向一个结果，而这个结果就是您将要提到的这款产品。
Oh, wait, are you talking about Bavarian meats little lamb yager snacks sticks?
哦，等等，你是在说巴伐利亚肉类小羊肉小吃棒吗？
We agreed, that's what, right before we started talking to Zoe said, that's what we're gonna talk about.
我们同意，这就是我们开始与佐伊交谈之前所说的，这就是我们要谈论的内容。
Well, this is what I wanna talk about.
嗯，这就是我想谈的。
The great tasting Bavarian meats, little lamb yager snacks sticks.
美味的巴伐利亚肉类、小羊肉小吃棒。
They sent us some of these and they are delicious and they solve the central problem of my life, which is I forget to eat.
他们给我们送来了一些，它们很美味，解决了我生活中的核心问题，那就是我忘记吃饭。
They're naturally fermented, They're made with real ingredients.
它们是自然发酵的，是用真正的原料制成的。
Slow smoked for bold flavor packed with nine grams of protein per serving and have zero sugar and zero carbs.
慢熏，味道浓郁，每份含有 9 克蛋白质，零糖和零碳水化合物。
Also, I have a 19 year old boy.
另外，我有一个19岁的男孩。
Also a good moment to get a bunch of this product because he will eat us out of house and home.
这也是购买一堆这种产品的好时机，因为他会把我们吃得满屋子和家里。
And he loves this stuff.
他喜欢这个东西。
It's so great.
太棒了。
I'm very grateful we got, we got to sample this.
我非常感激我们得到了这个，我们必须对此进行采样。
My son is gonna eat it all.
我儿子会把它全部吃掉。
I'm gonna have like none of it.
我什么都不会。
But okay, it's a snack that keeps up with your day, whether you're racing between meetings or feeding babies or 19 year olds.
但没关系，无论您是在赶会议还是在给婴儿或 19 岁的孩子喂奶，它都是一款适合您一天的零食。
doing school drop off, just trying to finish your to-do list, take a moment to savor something delicious for you or your children.
放学时，只是想完成您的待办事项清单，花点时间为您或您的孩子品尝美味的东西。
And did we mention they're portable, toss a few in your glove box, your gym bag, the diaper bag, wherever.
我们是否提到过它们是便携式的，可以在您的手套箱、健身包、尿布包等任何地方放一些。
We have a diaper bag.
我们有一个尿布袋。
I bet you do.
我打赌你会的。
Two or three of those bad boys.
两三个坏男孩。
Pick up a pack today, your local grocer or stock up at bavarianmeats.com slash podcast.
立即从当地杂货店购买一包，或在 bavarianmeats.com 斜线播客上购买。
Use code Mother 10 Mother 10 at checkout for 10% off your first order.
结帐时使用代码 Mother 10 Mother 10，首次订单可享受 10% 折扣。
The variant meets snacks, sticks, great taste, zero sugar.
该变体满足零食、棒状、美味、零糖的需求。
I could talk for hours about every single episode of how I met your mother.
我可以谈论几个小时关于我如何遇见你母亲的每一件事。
And we do, but when it comes to my own health, I used to be pretty clueless.
我们确实如此，但当谈到我自己的健康时，我过去却一无所知。
I'd shrug off low energy, or fitness plates I was just stressed, basically guessing about what my body actually needed.
我会摆脱低能量或我只是感到压力的健身板，基本上猜测我的身体实际需要什么。
But you shouldn't guess when it comes to your health.
但当涉及到您的健康时，您不应该猜测。
Instead, you should get the real data that supports your wellness with lab core on-demand health testing.
相反，您应该通过实验室核心按需健康测试来获取支持您健康的真实数据。
On the website, you can choose from a suite of more than 100 health tests, including micronutrient allergy, testosterone, fitness, sexual wellness, and more, all available to purchase without a doctor's appointment.
在该网站上，您可以从 100 多项健康测试中进行选择，包括微量营养素过敏、睾酮、健身、性健康等，所有这些都可以在无需医生预约的情况下购买。
Just purchase a test online and visit a local lab core location to have your sample collected.
只需在线购买测试并访问当地实验室核心地点即可收集样本。
It's so simple.
就是这么简单。
Within days, you'll have accurate results that are easy to understand from a lab doctor's trust.
几天之内，您将获得实验室医生信任的易于理解的准确结果。
To start your journey, visit ondemand.labcore.com slash mother and use code mother to save up to 15% on select tests.
要开始您的旅程，请访问 ondemand.labcore.comlash mother 并使用 code mother 在精选测试中节省高达 15% 的费用。
That's ondemand.labcore.com slash mother and use code mother.
这就是 ondemand.labcore.com 斜线母亲和使用代码母亲。
Know yourself.
了解你自己。
End of commercials back to show.
广告结束返回放映。
Can I ask both of you how present were you at the time?
我能问一下你们当时在场的情况如何吗？
I mean, Craig, like you would describe to me all of a sudden you go from writer to owner of rather large small business with millions of dollars on the line.
我的意思是，克雷格，就像你向我描述的那样，你突然从作家变成了拥有数百万美元的大型小型企业的所有者。
And you know, you're going all over, were you able to appreciate this in the moment?
你知道，你已经彻底崩溃了，那一刻你能体会到这一点吗？
Could you breathe through it and go look what we're doing here?
你能呼吸一下并看看我们在这里做什么吗？
I think I did because I like we didn't know if the show was that we thought that was it.
我想我这样做是因为我喜欢我们不知道这个节目是否是我们认为的那样。
We were shooting a pilot and we're like, I can't believe we got it this far.
我们当时正在拍摄试播集，我们想，我不敢相信我们能走到这一步。
We'll be able to show this to our friends.
我们将能够向我们的朋友展示这个。
I mean, I did have this feeling that something was magical about like a moment like watching Josh do that speech on that location shoot outside on New York Street.
我的意思是，我确实有一种感觉，就像看到乔什在纽约街外的那个拍摄地点做演讲的那一刻一样，有一些神奇的东西。
Like I had the feeling like this is gonna go, but you don't know.
就像我有预感这一切都会过去，但你不知道。
It was just like let's make this one good episode and we'll see if it ever goes in there.
就像让我们把这一集打造成精彩的一集，然后看看它是否会出现在那里。
Probably it won't.
可能不会。
The odds are against you, way against you.
机会对你不利，完全对你不利。
So I didn't yet feel that like we're running a big business.
所以我还不觉得我们在经营一家大企业。
I was like we have this amount of money and this number of days and these actors let's make the best 22-minute show we can.
我当时想，我们有这么多钱和这么多天，这些演员让我们尽我们所能制作最好的 22 分钟节目。
And it felt very fleeting.
这感觉非常短暂。
And maybe that was part of its magic.
也许这就是它的魔力的一部分。
It felt absolutely fleeting.
感觉绝对是转瞬即逝的。
In that way, it felt very innocent because you look back now and you're like, well, of course, we know now they're going to do 208 episodes of this, 207 more.
这样一来，感觉非常无辜，因为你现在回头看，你会想，好吧，当然，我们现在知道他们会制作 208 集，还有 207 集。
But at the time, we were just trying to make a good show that would get the attention of the network and that would put us on the air.
但当时，我们只是想制作一个好的节目来引起网络的关注，从而让我们播出。
One good episode.
不错的一集。
Yeah.
是的。
One good episode, right?
很好的一集，对吧？
One good one.
一件好事。
And another thing I loved watching it, just to tick off some more things that jumped out of me watching it.
还有一件事是我喜欢看它，只是为了勾选一些我在观看它时跳出来的东西。
And then I'm dying to hear more about what it was like watching with Jordana, I really am.
然后我很想听到更多关于和乔丹娜一起观看比赛的感觉，我真的很想知道。
I know we were saving that made for the end just so I'm just so curious But one you know what I loved how there everything was important everything was important right away the whole episode begins with Marshall Changed my whole world you changed the game you screwed everything up by getting engaged That's a big deal.
我知道我们正在为最后做准备，所以我很好奇，但你知道我喜欢什么，一切都很重要，一切都很重要，整集从马歇尔开始，改变了我的整个世界，你改变了游戏，你订婚了，一切都搞砸了，这是一件大事。
You're best friend got engaged.
你最好的朋友订婚了。
So Ted decides.
于是特德做出了决定。
I'm gonna go meet the love of my life And all these important things start happening right and all these like everything feels high stakes It all takes place in this one night.
我要去见我一生的挚爱 所有这些重要的事情都开始发生，所有这些就像一切都感觉风险很大 这一切都发生在这一晚。
We I love all the time jumps but the stakes of the show are one night and I love that in the background of this and raising the stakes in this weird kind of stealthy way that people might not notice.
我们一直喜欢跳跃，但演出的赌注是一晚，我喜欢在这个背景下，以人们可能不会注意到的这种奇怪的隐秘方式提高赌注。
There's a guy on a bridge who's going to jump off the bridge in Robin's news story.
在罗宾的新闻报道中，桥上有一个人要跳桥。
And I think it's so important to the pilot that there's this life or death tension just ticking this little clock ticking in the background.
我认为这对飞行员来说非常重要，因为背景中的小时钟滴答作响，生死攸关的紧张气氛。
Is that guy going to jump off that bridge?
那家伙会从桥上跳下去吗？
And how that sort of factors back into like like the moment Ted, you know, the moment in the bar where they see that he didn't jump, and Marshall says he didn't jump, which first of all, I felt it's relief.
这类因素如何回到像特德那一刻，你知道，在酒吧里他们看到他没有跳的那一刻，马歇尔说他没有跳，首先，我觉得这是一种解脱。
I was like, oh, thank God, that guy didn't jump.
我当时想，哦，谢天谢地，那家伙没有跳下去。
Like I was just like back into it.
就像我又回到了过去一样。
And it's just like that idea of these high stakes and it's all life for death.
这就像这些高风险的想法一样，都是生死攸关。
This is our life.
这就是我们的生活。
This is our life right now.
这就是我们现在的生活。
Tonight is gonna be a story, be tall forever.
今晚将是一个故事，永远高高在上。
Are we gonna live?
我们还能活下去吗？
Are we gonna die?
我们会死吗？
Are we gonna take the leap?
我们要迈出这一步吗？
Are we gonna not take the leap?
我们不打算迈出这一步吗？
Is taking the leap good or bad?
飞跃是好是坏？
Ted is a great joke about that.
特德对此开了一个很大的玩笑。
And but boy, I just, I loved how everything felt like the most important thing in the world and that pie.
但是天哪，我只是，我喜欢一切都感觉像是世界上最重要的事情，还有那个馅饼。
What is it in the van that pulls up is we got a jumper.
停在车里的东西是我们有一件套头衫。
We got a jumper.
我们有一件毛衣。
Yeah, that was the one that was like, does the news van just pull up in front of our apartment?
是的，就是这样的，新闻车就停在我们公寓前面了吗？
There you are.
你就在那里。
We've been looking for you.
我们一直在找你。
We've been looking.
我们一直在寻找。
Where have they been looking?
他们一直在寻找什么？
Where have they come to the restaurant?
他们到哪儿来的餐厅？
How would they know?
他们怎么知道？
Did it work?
有效吗？
Trackers on our phones, yes.
我们手机上的追踪器，是的。
Greg, you pointed out that you didn't know if there would be more than one episode.
格雷格，你指出你不知道是否会有不止一集。
This was what you were doing.
这就是你正在做的事情。
And you sort of put your all into it.
而你则投入了全部的精力。
I think one thing that shows out in this pilot, very much so, is, yes, it launches a series, the way a great pilot launches.
我认为这个试播集中表现出的一件事是，是的，它推出了一个系列，就像一个伟大的试播集一样。
It's also just a great romantic comedy in 22 minutes.
这也是一部22分钟的精彩浪漫喜剧。
You kind of have a whole movie happening in here.
好像一整部电影都在这里发生。
And like you were saying, because everything is so important, it has that cinematic feel, and it's got that story going on in the background, and it has this romantic lead going through quite a bit.
就像你说的，因为一切都如此重要，所以它有电影般的感觉，并且有故事在背景中进行，而且它有一个浪漫的主角经历了相当多的时间。
You just happen to, and this romantic story with not getting the girl instead of getting the girl.
你只是碰巧，这个浪漫的故事没有得到女孩而不是得到女孩。
Yeah, but it really felt like you piled in a full tail in here.
是的，但感觉就像你在这里堆满了尾巴。
And I think that's why it gets a lot done in a hurry.
我认为这就是为什么它会匆忙完成很多工作。
It gets a lot done in a hurry.
很快就能完成很多事情。
I was also proud of that.
我也为此感到自豪。
Like by the end of act one, I made a little note to myself like, so much has happened, so which has happened in act one.
就像第一幕结束时，我给自己做了一个小笔记，就像发生了很多事情，所以第一幕中也发生了这些。
Like it's like, you know, so much very quickly and so much has happened.
就好像，你知道，很快，发生了很多事情。
I also loved another little moment.
我也喜欢另一个小时刻。
I love that Robin's friend in the corner going, what's taking so long, you know, calling out.
我喜欢罗宾的朋友在角落里走来走去，你知道，怎么花了这么长时间才大声喊叫。
kind of like, it's just a hilarious thing to look back at and go, little did we know how it's going to be 208 episodes.
有点像，回顾起来真是一件很搞笑的事情，我们几乎不知道这会是 208 集。
That woman, that was the truest line in the whole pilot.
那个女人，那是整部剧里最真实的台词。
It was the woman who goes, what's taking so long?
是那个女人走的，怎么这么久？
Because the whole thing was going to take longer than anyone ever thought.
因为整个事情需要的时间比任何人想象的都要长。
And we brought her back and you're the end of the show.
我们把她带回来了，演出就结束了。
I love the what's taking so long, girl.
我喜欢花这么长时间的事情，女孩。
It sort of, it sort of became like the theme of the show.
这有点像节目的主题。
What's taking so long?
什么事要花这么长时间？
Well, we're going to take not a fucking year, it's so long, isn't it?
好吧，我们不需要他妈的一年，太长了，不是吗？
Robin and Ted are talking.
罗宾和泰德正在谈话。
Robin and Ted are talking and she wants to, yeah, Yeah.
罗宾和泰德正在说话，她想，是的，是的。
The friend wants her to come back to the corner.
朋友希望她回到角落。
Because she just had to break up.
因为她刚刚不得不分手。
He just had to break up.
他只得分手。
And she's miserable.
她很痛苦。
And she hates all of that.
她讨厌这一切。
Yeah.
是的。
She hates all of that.
她讨厌这一切。
And she wants, she wants, she wants, she's like, where's my next round?
她想要，她想要，她想要，她就像，我的下一轮在哪里？
Where I need to get drunker than this.
我哪里需要比这更醉的地方。
I just got dumped.
我刚刚被甩了。
And that exchange, that also was so great.
那次交流，也太棒了。
But the other moment I thought, I mean, many moments I thought, hey, this might go somewhere.
但另一个时刻我想，我的意思是，很多时候我想，嘿，这可能会有所进展。
You and Robin up at that bar, Ted and Robin up at that bar, and the whole thing that ends with the drink in the face, which was one of the audition scenes that got both of you cast, because you were magic even in an audition.
你和罗宾在那个酒吧，泰德和罗宾在那个酒吧，整个事情以喝到脸上的酒结束，这是你们俩都选角的试镜场景之一，因为即使在试镜中你们也很神奇。
Um, that was another moment where I was like, ah, I remember feeling pretty good in that scene.
嗯，那是另一个时刻，我想，啊，我记得在那个场景中感觉很好。
I mean, all over the place.
我的意思是，到处都是。
I was feeling pretty, pretty good about it.
我感觉很漂亮，非常好。
Do you remember also it was the very last thing we shot was with Rungeet around the table at the bar.
你还记得吗，我们拍摄的最后一幕是和 Rungeet 一起在酒吧的桌子旁拍摄的。
The funny reveal that Rungeet is with us.
有趣的是，朗吉特和我们在一起。
Oh, my God.
我的天啊。
Signal.
信号。
Rungeet, what?
朗吉特，什么？
He's so good.
他太好了。
Marshall.
马歇尔。
He's so good.
他太好了。
Marshall, man.
马歇尔，伙计。
How many episodes?
有几集？
He ended up doing what?
他最后做了什么？
20 episodes?
20集？
He did a bunch.
他做了一堆。
Yeah.
是的。
He was an important, he was, oh man.
他是个重要人物，他是，天哪。
Him, him also kind of shutting out of your signal.
他，他也有点拒绝你的信号。
That was a signal.
那是一个信号。
Yeah.
是的。
remember, they gave us real champagne to one hell of a night to one hell of a night.
请记住，他们为我们提供了真正的香槟，度过了一个痛苦的夜晚。
Yeah, they gave us real champagne, which is not something I've done a lot on a set.
是的，他们给了我们真正的香槟，这不是我在片场经常做的事情。
But it was, it was the last night of the shooting of the pilot and we all had a little bit of champagne.
但事实确实如此，那是飞行员拍摄的最后一晚，我们都喝了一点香槟。
There was just such a warm, good feeling on set.
现场有一种温暖、美好的感觉。
Like, I think we made something good.
就像，我认为我们做了一些好事。
That's what it felt like, right?
就是这样的感觉，对吧？
It felt like we had made something good.
感觉就像我们做了一些好事。
It felt like we had made the thing we set out to make.
感觉就像我们已经做出了我们打算做的事情。
It really felt that way in life, any endeavor in life, especially a TV pilot too.
生活中确实有这种感觉，生活中的任何努力，尤其是电视飞行员也是如此。
It doesn't always feel that way, and it just, it had this mad, there was just a magic to it.
它并不总是那样的感觉，而且它只是，它是如此疯狂，它只是一种魔力。
I just felt like a magic and a life to it and something that was bigger than the sum of its parts and bigger than me or you or anything.
我只是觉得它有一种魔力，有一种生命，一种比各部分总和还要大的东西，比我、你或任何东西都大。
And it was like, I felt so much gratitude watching it and so much gratitude to the fans because people found that it was a weird, it was a weird show for CBS.
就像，我对观看它感到非常感激，也非常感谢粉丝，因为人们发现这是一个奇怪的节目，对于哥伦比亚广播公司来说这是一个奇怪的节目。
With a weird title.
带着一个奇怪的标题。
Weird title.
奇怪的标题。
Oh, I mean, we tested that pilot and we're told, so after, you have this magic time sheeting the pilot and then you take it and you take it to these focus groups and you put it through this somewhat corporate testing process, which every pilot does, and one of the takeaways from the testing was people hate the title.
哦，我的意思是，我们测试了那个试点，我们被告知，所以之后，你有这个神奇的时间表，然后你把它带到这些焦点小组，你把它通过这个某种程度上的公司测试过程，每个试点都会这样做，而测试的要点之一是人们讨厌这个标题。
It was like, I remember the testing people being like, everyone's confused by this.
就像，我记得测试人员的样子，每个人都对此感到困惑。
I've strong recommendation to change this, and they were saying in front of the studio executives, I was like, don't shut up, don't do this, can we talk over here away from them?
我强烈建议改变这一点，他们在工作室高管面前说，我想，不要闭嘴，不要这样做，我们可以在这里远离他们谈谈吗？
Because we did not want to change the title.
因为我们不想更改标题。
The title is the thing, thank God.
感谢上帝，标题就是重点。
Again, the studio and the network, they believed on the show, they knew the title, sold the show.
同样，工作室和网络，他们相信这部剧，他们知道片名，卖掉了这部剧。
And so we didn't.
所以我们没有。
But there was there were discussions is a title to confusing that those time jumps I talked about, boom, boom, boom, what, what, sure enough, some people in the focus group that were, that it, you know, accepted $50 to watch a pilot on a Sunday afternoon in the Valley.
但有一些讨论是一个令人困惑的标题，我谈到的那些时间跳跃，繁荣，繁荣，繁荣，什么，什么，果然，焦点小组中的一些人，你知道，接受 50 美元在周日下午在山谷观看飞行员。
It would want to enter in from the mall next door or whatever.
它想从隔壁的商场或其他地方进入。
They were like, I don't get it.
他们说，我不明白。
What's that's weird?
这有什么奇怪的？
And if you were asked, did that confuse you?
如果有人问你，这会让你感到困惑吗？
and you go, yeah, that is confusing.
然后你就走了，是的，这很令人困惑。
What a jump to the future, what happened?
多么跳跃到未来，发生了什么？
And people, so it's very nerve-wracking when you put something this intricate and unique through that process and you're just terrified, it's gonna come out.
人们，所以当你把如此复杂和独特的东西放入这个过程中时，你会感到害怕，它会出来，这是非常令人伤脑筋的。
The worst thing.
最糟糕的事情。
It didn't, it really didn't.
没有，真的没有。
When you were talking about how much had already happened by the end of Act One, I feel like because of the narrative structure, it's such a plot heavy show, it's such a propulsive show.
当你谈到第一幕结束时已经发生了多少事情时，我觉得由于叙事结构，这是一个情节沉重的节目，这是一个如此推进的节目。
So it doesn't, it can't withstand a lot of fat on it.
所以不是的，它不能承受上面有很多脂肪。
It's like everything was trimmed down to its essence, which is astonishing because my memory of doing the show while the plot is delightful and strange and always surprising, you still get so many good jokes in there, but they're character revealing and they're plot forwarding all the dress.
就好像一切都被精简到了本质，这很令人惊讶，因为我记得做这部剧的时候，情节是令人愉快、奇怪的，总是令人惊讶，你仍然会在里面看到很多好笑话，但它们揭示了人物的性格，而且它们正在转发所有服装的情节。
They're one or the other or both.
它们是其中之一或另一个或两者兼而有之。
That's exactly it.
就是这样。
They're character revealing or plot forwarding or both.
它们是人物揭示或情节转发或两者兼而有之。
There's almost nothing that isn't that.
几乎没有什么不是这样的。
And by the way, just that didn't start that way.
顺便说一句，事情并不是这样开始的。
That cut of that pilot came in.
那个试播集的片段进来了。
It's supposed to be 22 minutes.
应该是22分钟。
I think it was 31 minutes.
我记得是 31 分钟。
Overshot.
过冲。
We cut out whole scenes with all this fat.
我们用这些脂肪剪掉了整个场景。
We learned so much editing that show.
我们在剪辑那个节目中学到了很多东西。
It really was built in the editor room on a lot of ways.
它确实是通过多种方式在编辑室中构建的。
And when you see the edited version and you're just heartbroken most of the time because you're like, oh, that's gone.
当你看到编辑后的版本时，大多数时候你都会心碎，因为你会想，哦，那已经消失了。
I love that.
我喜欢那个。
Where did that go?
那去哪儿了？
No, this just got better.
不，这只是变得更好了。
This just got better.
这变得更好了。
Everything we cut out, we should have cut out.
我们删掉的一切，我们都应该删掉。
everything.
一切。
Oh my God, it was so overwritten.
天哪，居然被重写了。
It came in so fat.
它进来的时候太胖了。
It wasn't great at first, and we whittled it down on what you did.
一开始效果并不好，我们根据您所做的事情进行了缩减。
Yeah.
是的。
I have two questions.
我有两个问题。
One, where are the all of theory come from?
一、所有的理论从何而来？
Um, I think that was, that was, I think that was also a Carter-based gem, because, but, but it's funny because it was sort of a martial and lily thing.
嗯，我认为那是，那是，我认为这也是一个基于卡特的宝石，因为，但是，但这很有趣，因为它是一种武术和百合的东西。
Am I to mean, might have been Carter's observation of like, you know, being close friends with me and seeing maybe this old married guy at age, you know, 20, 21.
我的意思是，可能是卡特的观察，你知道，与我成为亲密朋友，并在20岁、21岁的时候看到这个已婚老男人。
I mean, that basically.
我的意思是，基本上就是这样。
And then even more so by the time I was 30 and like the negotiations of couple.
到了30岁的时候更是如此，我喜欢夫妻间的谈判。
I think it was Carter's like stealth commentary on like, you know, watching a guy in a relationship like bend a little bit and choose your battles.
我认为这是卡特的秘密评论，你知道，看着一个处于恋爱关系中的男人稍微弯曲一下并选择你的战斗。
And I don't know why I wouldn't want to dissweet this person of this thing.
我不知道为什么我不想让这个人对这件事感到厌恶。
And like I think it was, I think it was Carter's clever, clever commentary slash slite discs on maybe my, my close friend watching me in a relationship with a strong woman and I was like, I don't want it.
就像我认为的那样，我认为这是卡特在也许是我的、我的亲密朋友上观看我与一个坚强的女人的关系的聪明、聪明的评论斜线光盘，我当时想，我不想要它。
It was sort of, I think it was like, I think it was a little bit fat, which I got hit any day.
我觉得有点胖，我每天都会受到打击。
The only thing in the pilot that I found that made me cringe and I think would probably you would not write today is Barney's opening lines.
在试播集中，我发现唯一让我感到畏缩的地方，我想你今天可能不会写的是巴尼的开场白。
Right.
正确的。
Yeah.
是的。
It's like he's talking about like, yeah, what type of women he likes and I used to like this kind of thing.
就像他在谈论，是的，他喜欢什么类型的女人，而我曾经喜欢这种事情。
Yeah, it feels a little insensitive and obviously that's kind of who Barney is.
是的，感觉有点麻木不仁，显然巴尼就是这样的人。
It's kind of, I thought the same thing.
有点像，我也这么想。
I felt a little bit not proud of that, but I felt like, that was our opening thing for Barney, what are we doing?
我对此感到有点不自豪，但我觉得，这是我们为巴尼做的开场白，我们在做什么？
I will say, what are we doing?
我会说，我们在做什么？
It's a tricky thing, and this is something we'll probably unpack about that characters we go, but it's a tricky thing where it's like, you never were actually endorsing Barney's worldview.
这是一件棘手的事情，我们可能会解开我们所扮演的角色，但这是一件棘手的事情，你从来没有真正认可过巴尼的世界观。
You were trying to write a character that had these very strange kind of out there ideas and schemes and all this stuff, Um, but it's a tricky thing when you're writing a character like that who's held up to not be like emulated, but to be slightly kind of mocked or roll your eyes at them.
你试图写一个有这些非常奇怪的想法和计划以及所有这些东西的角色，嗯，但当你写一个像这样的角色时，这是一件棘手的事情，他不会被模仿，而是会被轻微嘲笑或对他们翻白眼。
But then you get people, it's kind of like Michael Douglas in Wall Street, you know, all of her stone, who's as lefty of filmmakers you could get created a character that like finance bros in college like had Gordon Gecko posters on their wall.
但你会发现人们，这有点像华尔街的迈克尔·道格拉斯，你知道，她是电影制片人中的左撇子，你可以创造出一个像大学里的金融兄弟一样的角色，就像墙上贴着戈登·壁虎的海报一样。
I know.
我知道。
And they started, it's like they missed the entire condemnation, right?
他们开始了，就好像他们错过了整个谴责，对吧？
Right.
正确的。
And that's, that happens with Barney.
巴尼就是这样。
You know, Barney, we imagine Barney as a parody of toxic masculinity.
你知道，巴尼，我们把巴尼想象成有毒男子气概的模仿者。
And underneath it, there's this very needy human who wants Ted to put on a suit, play laser tag and be his best friend.
在它的下面，有一个非常需要帮助的人，他希望泰德穿上西装，玩激光枪战并成为他最好的朋友。
That's what I loved in this pilot.
这就是我喜欢这个试播集的地方。
Reminded me of like the original intention of Barney.
让我想起喜欢Barney的初衷。
Like I was watching the pilot and I thought to myself.
就像我在看飞行员一样，我心里想。
Barney on Saturday night is playing laser tag with children by himself.
周六晚上，巴尼正在独自和孩子们玩激光枪战。
Yeah, it's quite sad.
是啊，真是太悲伤了。
It's sad in a way and it's like he really wanted Ted to come and Ted didn't come.
从某种程度上来说，这是令人悲伤的，就好像他真的希望特德来，但特德没有来。
And he's pretending he's like late laser tag is so awesome, but he abandons laser tag immediately to come join Ted.
他假装自己觉得后期激光枪战太棒了，但他立即放弃了激光枪战，加入了特德。
And all he wants is for Ted to put on his suit and be reassured he's his best friend.
他想要的只是让特德穿上他的西装，让他放心，他是他最好的朋友。
And that is the essence of Barney.
这就是巴尼的本质。
I was proud of that because sometimes we do, So many people watch Barney and they think he's to be emulated.
我为此感到自豪，因为有时我们会这样做，很多人都在观看巴尼，他们认为他值得效仿。
So many people watch Barney and they go, you couldn't get away with that now.
很多人看着巴尼，然后他们就走了，你现在无法逃脱。
And I guess my response to that for me, and it doesn't mean we always hit the target here, but for me, we were never trying to get away with that.
我想我对此的反应对我来说并不意味着我们总是达到目标，但对我来说，我们从来没有试图逃脱惩罚。
We were always trying to make a caricature and a parody.
我们一直在尝试制作漫画和模仿作品。
And then even as early as a pilot, we were trying to dig underneath that bravado, and that suit and see this kind of needy human vulnerable person underneath.
甚至早在飞行员时期，我们就试图挖掘这种虚张声势和西装的底蕴，并看到底下这种有需要的人类弱势群体。
And I could point to a lot of other episodes with Barney where we tried to do that down the line.
我可以指出巴尼的许多其他剧集，我们试图在接下来的过程中做到这一点。
And I think that was the genetic code, the DNA code of Barney and the pilot.
我认为这就是遗传密码，巴尼和飞行员的 DNA 密码。
I think the best Barney moments through the series did that.
我认为巴尼在整个系列中最好的时刻就是这么做的。
And maybe the ones where we were just doing like Barney jokes that became single on Honduras, or became like, became sort of one level.
也许我们刚刚做的那些事情就像巴尼笑话一样，在洪都拉斯变成了单身，或者变得像，变成了一种水平。
And maybe we did too much of that at times.
也许我们有时做得太多了。
And it was like, we weren't making the commentary about Barney.
就好像我们没有对巴尼进行评论。
We weren't showing the person underneath.
我们没有展示下面的人。
I'm sure we did plenty of that that made that probably doesn't hold up as well But I think the moments where we were showing the human the needy human underneath at all That's that's that was the character that was the character and Neil Neil played that so Beautifully you really get that in the pilot.
我确信我们做了很多这样的事情，这可能也不会持续下去，但我认为我们向人类展示内心深处有需要的人的那一刻，那就是这个角色，尼尔·尼尔扮演的角色非常漂亮，你真的可以在试播集中得到这一点。
I think and that you know what else I was struck by is um how late they stayed up Being our age.
我想你知道让我震惊的还有什么是他们在我们这个年纪熬夜到很晚。
I was so tired watching it I was like it's got to be it's like 145 like they're gonna meet at the bar for last round like I was so tired.
我看着它太累了，我想这一定是145，就像他们最后一轮会在酒吧见面一样，就像我太累了一样。
I was watching it at like 953 at night and I was like, I mean, I got it.
我晚上在 953 频道观看，当时我想，我是说，我明白了。
Start turning this off pretty soon.
很快就开始关闭它。
I'll ruin my next day if I don't get to sleep.
如果我不睡觉的话我第二天就会毁掉。
Josh, just to have it on the record, do you remember what the first scene, the first scene you shot was of this whole, this whole show?
乔什，只是为了记录下来，你还记得你拍摄的第一个场景是什么，整个节目吗？
It might have been the first one.
这可能是第一个。
It might have been Marshall, like the fake out that he was proposing to me.
可能是马歇尔，就像他向我求婚时的假象一样。
That's, I think it was.
就是这样，我认为是这样。
I think it was that.
我想就是这样。
I think it was Jason proposing.
我认为是杰森求婚的。
on his bed.
在他的床上。
I think that was it.
我想就是这样。
I think we said let's start at the beginning because that's essentially the first scene that it's sort of like a montage and photos and music and that's it.
我想我们说让我们从头开始，因为这本质上是第一个场景，它有点像蒙太奇、照片和音乐，仅此而已。
And I think Pam again, our director was very smart to say let's begin at the beginning and let's end at the ending.
我再次认为帕姆，我们的导演非常聪明地说让我们从头开始，让我们在结局结束。
I'll have to jumble in between, but let's give ourselves that frame.
我将不得不在两者之间混淆，但让我们给自己一个框架。
That is it.
就是这样。
That's what it was.
And it was you and Jason together.
那是你和杰森在一起。
We haven't talked much about how great Jason is in the pilot and what a great best friend chemistry you guys had immediately in that scene that sets the whole tone for the day.
我们还没有过多谈论杰森在试播集中的表现有多出色，以及你们在那个场景中立即产生的最好的朋友化学反应，这为当天的整体基调奠定了基础。
You're always making me laugh was the three of them in the cab waiting downstairs.
他们三个在出租车里等在楼下，你总是让我发笑。
There is really funny.
确实有搞笑的地方。
And this is a really good thing to actually talk about.
这是一件值得真正谈论的好事情。
One of the things we all talked about and agreed, the cast, you, Carter, Pam was the idea on a sitcom.
我们都讨论并同意的事情之一，演员、你、卡特、帕姆是情景喜剧的想法。
Most sitcoms, people are saying hilarious stuff and no one ever laughs.
大多数情景喜剧，人们都在说搞笑的话，但没有人笑。
But we decided as friends in a show that we wanted to have some very similar to it, if someone said something that was clearly meant to be a joke, we would laugh at it.
但我们决定作为一个节目中的朋友，我们想要一些非常相似的东西，如果有人说一些明显是开玩笑的话，我们会嘲笑它。
Or she was not the last.
或者她不是最后一个。
But yeah, but react.
但是，是的，但是反应。
Yeah, Barney and Marshall are really making each other laugh.
是的，巴尼和马歇尔真的让彼此开怀大笑。
And I think Neil and Jason were really making each other laugh in the back of that cab.
我认为尼尔和杰森在出租车后座上真的让彼此开怀大笑。
And there's something really charming and real about it.
它有一些非常迷人和真实的东西。
That is a great observation that carried through the whole series.
这是贯穿整个系列的一个伟大的观察。
And I think made the show feel real or door to door because he would always cut in these reaction shots.
我认为让这部剧感觉真实或挨家挨户，因为他总是会切入这些反应镜头。
Like someone says something at the booth and you cut to them laughing.
就像有人在展位上说了些什么，然后你就切到他们大笑一样。
And I thought it made the show kind of extra charming that we weren't oblivious to humor.
我认为这让这部剧变得格外迷人，因为我们并没有忽视幽默。
Jason was really good at that.
杰森真的很擅长这一点。
He would be loud.
他会很大声。
He would be like, he was amused to being in that pilot.
他会说，他对参加试播集感到很有趣。
Like, he was having a good time in a show and he was happy to be there.
就像，他在一场演出中玩得很开心，他很高兴能在那里。
And like, you really felt that and you felt that between you guys, yeah.
就像，你真的感觉到了，你们之间也感觉到了，是的。
And they're in them down that cab is great.
他们就在里面，出租车很棒。
And even Barney's saying to Marshall, when they're alone that cab, don't get married.
甚至巴尼也对马歇尔说，当他们单独坐在出租车上时，不要结婚。
Even that felt big.
即使这样也感觉很大。
It's like he just got engaged with that day and Barney's going, don't get married.
就好像他那天刚刚订婚，巴尼就走了，别结婚了。
Like there was so many, like every scene had some high stakes thing in it or two or three of them.
就像有这么多，就像每个场景都有一些高风险的东西，或者其中有两三个。
Yeah.
是的。
Like that.
就这样。
Even that snuck jumped out of me or it's like, that's important.
就连那件事也从我身上跳了出来，或者说，这很重要。
That's one of his close friends saying, you're making a horrible mistake on the biggest day of his life proposing to Lily.
他的一位密友说，在他一生中最重要的一天向莉莉求婚，你犯了一个可怕的错误。
It's a bold swing.
这是一个大胆的转变。
Well, it's also like they say who you marry is the most important decision you'll ever make.
嗯，就像他们说你嫁给谁是你所做的最重要的决定一样。
I mean, this is high stakes stuff anyway.
我的意思是，无论如何，这都是高风险的事情。
It's high stakes.
这是高风险的。
And Barney's afraid of losing Marshall.
巴尼害怕失去马歇尔。
I'm going to lose Marshall.
我将失去马歇尔。
I'll never see Marshall again.
我再也见不到马歇尔了
He's going to get married and go away, which again is that thing from Barney.
他要结婚然后离开，这又是巴尼的那句话。
doesn't want to lose people because, well, we dig into Bernie's childhood later in the show and we see that you grew up with that a dad and, you know, he had to not have the easiest time of it.
不想失去人，因为，好吧，我们在节目后面深入探讨了伯尼的童年，我们看到你是和他的父亲一起长大的，你知道，他必须度过最轻松的时光。
And I like that you sense that in that pilot.
我喜欢你在飞行员身上感受到这一点。
Craig, can you just talk a little bit about Marshall and Lily since this is your, in some way, your marriage put up on screen that you decided to do about their, their story and what it was like now seeing them compared to how you were thinking about it back then?
克雷格，你能简单谈谈马歇尔和莉莉吗，因为从某种程度上来说，这是你的婚姻，你决定把他们的故事搬上银幕，以及现在看到他们的感觉与你当时的想法相比？
I just thought Jason and Allison were so sweet and daring and wonderful.
我只是觉得杰森和艾莉森是如此甜蜜、大胆和美妙。
But it just made me so happy to see, I liked remembering that this was a big part of the inception of the show, that they're the foundation, they're the adults, they're the parents, they're like, tell us about your date son, there's some kind of like emotional grounding and foundation to them that they bring, and Lily's more grown up than Marshall.
但这让我很高兴看到，我喜欢记住这是节目开始的一个重要部分，他们是基础，他们是成年人，他们是父母，他们就像，告诉我们你约会的儿子，他们给他们带来了某种情感基础和基础，莉莉比马歇尔更成熟。
Just like most women in their 20s are more grown up than men, as my wife fiance than wife was compared to me.
就像大多数20多岁的女性比男性更成熟一样，就像我的妻子未婚夫比妻子与我相比一样。
And I liked that dynamic.
我喜欢这种动态。
She was the grown-up.
她是成年人。
She comes in.
她进来了。
She has been felt up by a kindergartener.
一名幼儿园老师对她进行了摸摸。
She has a handprint on her boob.
她的胸部有一个手印。
And she just comes in and is so funny and charming.
她刚进来就非常有趣和迷人。
And Jason's more all over the place and insecure and a little bit of a lost puppy dog.
而杰森则更加不稳定，缺乏安全感，有点像一只迷路的小狗。
But he loves her so dearly.
但他是如此深爱她。
And the bond and foundation that they provide, I think, brings everything down to Earth in that episode.
我认为，他们提供的纽带和基础使这一集中的一切都变得现实。
And they're getting engaged.
他们要订婚了。
They're going to get married.
他们要结婚了。
They're the promise of what the whole season's going to be.
他们是整个赛季将会发生的事情的承诺。
There's going to be a wedding.
将会有一场婚礼。
This is big, important stuff, and you love them right away, I think.
这是一件大而重要的事情，我想你会立刻爱上它们。
I'm not saying I'm such a lovable person or my wife is, I like to think of it.
我并不是说我是一个多么可爱的人，或者我的妻子是一个多么可爱的人，我喜欢这样想。
They're very lovable.
他们非常可爱。
I mean, I think people, anybody that's come this far in the podcast already knows that.
我的意思是，我认为人们，任何在播客中走到这一步的人都已经知道了这一点。
But I really was, I was aware of how much they anchored the universe of that show.
但我确实是，我知道他们在很大程度上锚定了该剧的宇宙。
They were what Ted wanted to be, and the audience, they were the promise of what was going to happen in that season.
他们是特德想要成为的人，而观众，他们是那个赛季将要发生的事情的承诺。
They're going to get married.
他们要结婚了。
wedding, or are we, right?
婚礼，还是我们，对吧？
We later in the season, it gets complicated.
在赛季后期，情况会变得复杂。
I also remember, Josh, getting yelled at at TV Critics Association.
我还记得乔什在电视评论家协会被骂。
Remember, we had a, how I met your mother panel launching the pilot when the show got picked up.
请记住，我们有一个，我是如何遇见你的母亲小组的，当节目被选中时，他们启动了试播集。
And all the critics went after the other raise their hand, asked us questions for Q&A, and they were all like, so will you admit you made a mistake, not making Rob in the mother?
所有的批评家都在对方举手后，向我们提出问答问题，他们都说，所以你会承认你犯了一个错误，没有让罗布成为母亲吗？
They had such chemistry in the pilot.
他们在飞行员中产生了这样的化学反应。
Do you remember this?
你还记得这个吗？
I've done a himium style flash forward here where we're at a TV Critics Association event where you sort of of introduced we do a panel.
我在这里做了一个 hiium 风格的快闪，我们在电视评论家协会的活动上，你介绍了我们做了一个小组。
There's a few that were mad at you.
有几个人对你很生气。
They were mad at me and Carter.
他们对我和卡特很生气。
They were yelling at us and drilling us, setting the tone for many different moments where that would happen.
他们对我们大喊大叫，训练我们，为许多不同的时刻奠定了基调。
And I remember one guy saying, will you admit now that you made a mistake?
我记得一个人说，你现在愿意承认你犯了一个错误吗？
Now that we see the chemistry between Ted and Robin and now you're locked into this pilot ending that she's not the mother.
现在我们看到了泰德和罗宾之间的化学反应，现在你被锁定在这个试播集的结局中，她不是母亲。
You had the future dad say it's not the mother.
你让未来的爸爸说那不是妈妈。
Are you serious considering before it airs, going back and changing that.
你是否认真考虑过在播出前回去改变它。
And she's just the mother.
而她只是母亲。
And we're like, no.
我们的回答是，不。
And it was like, the show's over.
就像，演出结束了。
The show's over, right?
演出结束了，对吗？
And it's like, well, then I was like, what is the show after that?
就好像，好吧，然后我就想，之后的节目是什么？
The guy they're like, well, could just be about them.
他们喜欢的那个人，嗯，可能就是关于他们的。
They're, they're relationships.
他们是，他们是关系。
This is, this is, this is a, this is a bigger issue, which is people don't like to live with ambiguity.
这是、这是、这是一个、这是一个更大的问题，就是人们不喜欢生活在含糊之中。
They don't like to not know how something, they don't like the discomfort of this didn't work out the way we thought it was going to.
他们不喜欢不知道某件事是如何发生的，他们不喜欢事情没有按照我们想象的方式发展所带来的不适。
But you know what?
但你知道吗？
Neither does Ted.
特德也没有。
And neither does Ted.
And again, like you being mad at the, I love you moment now watching it when they went so many, when half the room was furious at us at this, it was like 300 TV critics.
再说一遍，就像你对“我爱你”的那一刻感到生气，当他们去了这么多的时候，当一半的房间对我们感到愤怒时，就像 300 名电视评论家一样。
They were mad at us.
他们对我们很生气。
And we, they were getting yelled at.
而我们，他们被吼叫。
I remember being like, Jesus Christ, I wish I had like had a couple whiskeys before coming out of the city.
我记得我当时想，天哪，我希望在出城之前能喝几杯威士忌。
And we were going to be tired and feathered.
我们会很累，而且羽毛很茂盛。
Like what's going on?
好像发生了什么事？
And I remember having been told by the CBS publicist Beth, they go, she was like, no, none of them are going to want to ask you a question.
我记得哥伦比亚广播公司公关贝丝告诉我，他们走了，她说，不，他们都不会想问你问题。
And they're going to ask Neil about doogie house or around scouts and about Buffy, you will get, you won't get two words.
他们会问尼尔关于杜吉之家或关于球探的事情，还有关于巴菲的事，你会得到，你不会得到两个词。
And it was like, first question, hey, I want to talk to those motherfuckers that didn't get time.
就像第一个问题，嘿，我想和那些没有时间的混蛋谈谈。
Can they step forward and be shamed?
他们能站出来受辱吗？
I always think it's funny when you tell a storyteller or creator, like I consumed everything you did.
我一直认为当你告诉一个讲故事的人或创作者时很有趣，就像我消耗了你所做的一切一样。
I have, I read everything or I watched the whole thing.
我读过所有内容，或者观看了整个内容。
And I am declaring to you that you did something wrong with it.
我向你宣布，你做错了事。
Here's where I would have done here's how I would have written it right.
这就是我会做的地方，这就是我正确写法的地方。
It's like it's not subtracted right your own story right.
就好像它没有减去你自己的故事一样。
Do go write your own story.
去写你自己的故事吧。
Yeah.
是的。
And and I but I remember later that night when I finally had had a couple of whiskeys, feeling like this was good that they got mad.
我，但我记得那天晚上晚些时候，当我终于喝了几杯威士忌时，感觉他们生气了，这很好。
Just like you said, it was good that you felt you were invested.
就像你说的，你觉得自己被投资了，这很好。
So when Ted said I love you, even now you got a mad way better than difference.
所以，当特德说我爱你时，即使是现在，你也比差异更好地发疯了。
Yeah.
是的。
Way better than boredom or indifference or swimmingess.
比无聊、冷漠或游手好闲要好得多。
And I will say Alison Hanigan got us out of that by because they did we were getting her rang about, well, you promised the mother and the title, and then you fucked it up in the end.
我想说艾莉森·哈尼根让我们摆脱了困境，因为他们做到了，我们给她打电话，好吧，你答应了母亲和头衔，然后你最后把它搞砸了。
And Alison Hanigan had this night where she goes, well, guys, think about it on who's the boss.
艾莉森·哈尼根（Alison Hanigan）今晚说，好吧，伙计们，想一想谁是老大。
You never found out who the boss was.
你永远不知道谁是老板。
Everybody in the TCA, everybody in the TCA, like cracked up laughing, like enormous laugh, enormous laugh.
TCA 中的每个人，TCA 中的每个人都笑得很开心，喜欢大笑，大笑。
And I was like, it saved us.
我当时想，它救了我们。
Also Alison Hanigan, like every couple of weeks would say the funniest thing I'd ever heard.
艾莉森·哈尼根（Alison Hanigan）每隔几周就会说出我听过的最有趣的事情。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
like she was like stealth.
就像她一样隐身。
She wasn't constantly cracking jokes.
她并不总是开玩笑。
Yes, just out of the blue, she was a really good one.
是的，出乎意料的是，她真的是一个很好的人。
She had to save it.
她必须保存它。
And she would just, it would detonate.
她只会，它会爆炸。
It was so, she's gonna be really funny.
原来如此，她一定会很有趣。
That joke lowered a helicopter ladder down and Carter and I just grabbed out of that joke and just were pulled out to save me.
那个笑话把直升飞机的梯子降了下来，我和卡特从那个笑话中挣脱出来，被拉出来救我。
No, yeah, so we can, we can introduce my lovely wife, Joanna, who is kind of part of the reason we're here.
不，是的，所以我们可以，我们可以介绍我可爱的妻子乔安娜，她是我们来这里的部分原因。
She's a lover of TV, it's hilarious.
她是电视爱好者，电视很搞笑。
She's seen many TV shows.
她看过很多电视剧。
And for some reason, she'd never seen a single episode of How I Made Mother's One.
出于某种原因，她从未看过《我如何制作母亲的一集》的一集。
It's not this one, which for me was a great relief when I met her.
不是这个，当我见到她时，这对我来说是一种很大的解脱。
I mean, it's one of those things where if people have seen the show, you don't get a chance to make a first impression with them.
我的意思是，如果人们看过这部剧，你就没有机会给他们留下第一印象。
They have this preconceived notion about you.
他们对你有这种先入为主的观念。
And it was just so wonderful that she hadn't seen the show.
这场演出实在是太精彩了，她竟然没有看过。
So it really, I trusted that she was with me for the right reasons, but we are now embarking on this rewatch together, our her first watch rather.
所以，我真的相信她和我在一起是出于正确的理由，但我们现在正在一起重新观看，而不是她的第一场观看。
We watched it the other night.
前几天晚上我们看了它。
I will say she, a couple of times, you know, when I was looking at Robin in a certain way, she would go, I know that look, I was going to ask, I was like, delicately going to try to ask that.
我会说她，有几次，你知道，当我以某种方式看着罗宾时，她会走，我知道那种表情，我要问，我当时想，小心翼翼地尝试问这个。
because you guys did a real chemistry in that pilot.
因为你们在那次试播中产生了真正的化学反应。
Again, 20 years before you ever met your dad.
再说一次，距离你遇见你父亲还有 20 年。
Yeah, yeah, that's what we're talking about.
是啊，是啊，这就是我们正在谈论的。
No, I mean, she was delighted.
不，我的意思是，她很高兴。
I think she can watch it with some objectivity and remove, you know, I don't think she's, I mean, it'd be silly for her to say, like, get away from that whoop thing.
我认为她可以客观地看待它，然后消除，你知道，我不认为她是，我的意思是，她说，比如，远离那个喧闹的事情是愚蠢的。
It was 2005.
那是2005年。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
Yeah, but she did record a question for us.
是的，但她确实为我们记录了一个问题。
So she, I don't know if she'll ever be on here live, but she's gonna slip off these voice notes so we can hear it.
所以她，我不知道她是否会在这里现场直播，但她会留下这些语音笔记，这样我们就能听到。
You use the word destiny at the end of the pilot, which is such a spiritual, powerful, meaning-centered word, and it's very comforting to think that we all have a destiny that the twists and turns are happening to each of us for a reason, but I'm wondering about your personal beliefs about destiny, your personal beliefs then, and now.
你在试播集的最后使用了“命运”这个词，这是一个精神上的、强大的、以意义为中心的词，想到我们都有一个命运，每个人的曲折都是有原因的，这让人感到非常安慰，但我想知道你对命运的个人信念，你过去和现在的个人信念。
And also what it was like to write a show you had total control over the destiny of five characters when we can feel so out of control when it comes to our own.
还有，当我们在自己的命运方面感到如此失控时，写一部完全控制五个角色命运的剧是什么感觉？
It's such a smart question.
这是一个非常聪明的问题。
We wrote this pilot, again, not really knowing if it would go beyond this.
我们再次编写了这个试播集，但并不真正知道它是否会超出这个范围。
And so we felt very much in the moment of that night.
所以那天晚上的那一刻我们感触良多。
We had ideas for where the show would go.
我们对演出的走向有想法。
But I never, even when we dove into really making it and having more and more ideas about how this would unfold.
但我从来没有这样做过，即使我们真正投入制作它并对如何展开有越来越多的想法。
I never felt like masters of these characters destiny.
我从来没有觉得自己是这些角色命运的主人。
I think Carter and I wanted to let these characters surprise us.
我想卡特和我想让这些角色给我们带来惊喜。
We wanted to respect these characters.
我们想尊重这些角色。
I came to have this delusional feeling like they were real people.
我开始有一种错觉，感觉他们是真人。
I really like, I hear writers talk about that and I don't always feel that way when I write stuff.
我真的很喜欢，我听到作家们谈论这一点，但当我写东西时我并不总是有这种感觉。
This was like by the end of how much your mother, these were real human beings to me.
这就像你的母亲对我来说是真正的人一样。
I didn't feel like some puppet master.
我不觉得自己像个木偶大师。
I felt like, I don't think Carter did either.
我觉得，我认为卡特也没有这么做。
I think we felt like, These are our friends and we're kind of seeing what happens to them.
我想我们的感觉是，这些是我们的朋友，我们正在看看他们会发生什么。
We're kind of guiding them.
我们有点引导他们。
Every now and again, we'd feel like, okay, we have to make something bad happen to one of them.
时不时地，我们会觉得，好吧，我们必须让其中一个人发生一些不好的事情。
We need, we need an emotional term.
我们需要，我们需要一个情感术语。
We need to explore something hard and it felt evil.
我们需要探索一些艰难的事情，这感觉很邪恶。
It felt evil.
感觉很邪恶。
That's part of what I get from Jordan and his question.
这是我从乔丹和他的问题中得到的部分信息。
We were controlling this destiny and we'd have to put them to this torture sometimes and especially Ted.
我们控制着这个命运，有时我们不得不让他们遭受这种折磨，尤其是特德。
And we'd have to make our dear friend Josh Radner go into this kind of pain and do things like saying, blurting out I love you to Kobe Smolders and her in her apartment in the pilot and make them crawl through hard shit so we could come out the other side and all kind of learn something together.
我们必须让我们亲爱的朋友乔什·拉德纳（Josh Radner）陷入这种痛苦，做一些事情，比如在试播集中的科比·斯莫尔德斯（Kobe Smolders）和她的公寓里脱口而出我爱你，让他们在艰难的环境中爬行，这样我们才能从另一边走出来，一起学习一些东西。
And often it was us making Carter myself, the other writers, stuff we took from Josh's life, other conversations we had with the actors.
通常是我们自己制作卡特，其他编剧，我们从乔什的生活中汲取的东西，以及我们与演员进行的其他对话。
Like we would take our own really hard shit And put the characters through some version of that.
就像我们会采取我们自己的非常艰难的方式，然后让角色经历某种版本的情况。
And so it felt shared.
所以感觉是共享的。
We tried to feel the pain with them.
我们试着和他们一起感受痛苦。
But was it strange to sort of come to feel like these were my friends almost like my family or my kids or something.
但感觉这些是我的朋友，几乎就像我的家人或我的孩子什么的，是不是有点奇怪。
And then sometimes put them through hell.
然后有时会让他们经历地狱。
But have this feeling like we're we all we knew it was all going to work out somehow in the end.
但要有这种感觉，就像我们都知道这一切最终都会以某种方式解决。
But even the end was complicated, right?
但即使是结局也很复杂，对吧？
And there is there a neat bow on any chapter of life ever really quite just sort of keeps going and complicating.
人生的任何一章都有一个简洁的蝴蝶结，真的只是不断地前进和复杂化。
and that sort of Ted's lesson in the pilot and in the series.
以及特德在试播集和剧集中的教训。
And so I guess I felt a great deal of respect and a great deep, almost delusional connection to these characters as we wrote them.
所以我想当我们写这些角色时，我对这些角色感到了极大的尊重和一种深刻的、近乎妄想的联系。
And I felt like I was going through it with them and sort of cathartically putting some of my own shit or Carter's shit or whatever into these characters' lives and seeing what happened to them.
我觉得我正在和他们一起经历这一切，并以一种宣泄的方式将我自己的一些狗屎或卡特的狗屎或其他什么东西放入这些角色的生活中，看看他们发生了什么。
But it was always with great care.
但总是非常小心。
Some of them as I felt very guilty.
他们中的一些人让我感到非常内疚。
I felt guilty making Ted go like, what do you use that conversation you cited, Josh, where you're like, can't Ted just have a good moment and not be kicked in the nuts of the next episode.
让泰德这样说，我感到内疚，你用你引用的那段对话做什么，乔什，你就像，泰德不能只是享受美好时光，而不会在下一集里被踢疯。
It's an interesting thing.
这是一件有趣的事情。
It becomes a seduatiatorial Roman Gladiator, like let's throw some lions in there and see what happens.
它变成了一个具有镇静作用的罗马角斗士，就像我们把一些狮子扔进去，看看会发生什么。
Did you and Carter talk so more globally about the idea of Destiny as a major theme of the show?
您和卡特是否在全球范围内广泛谈论过将命运作为该剧的主题的想法？
Yeah, I mean, we definitely, but also I think Destiny as defined in how much mother to me is sort of the sense you make of things later.
是的，我的意思是，我们当然，但我也认为命运的定义是对我来说有多少母亲是你后来对事物的理解。
I think in 2030, future Ted can see a sense of destiny and can see, or magic, whatever you want to call it.
我认为到 2030 年，未来的泰德可以看到一种命运感，可以看到，或者魔法，无论你怎么称呼它。
Or order.
或者订购。
Destiny sounds almost too neat for a lot of what happened on that show.
对于这部剧中发生的很多事情来说，命运听起来太完美了。
I mean, Destiny puts you in certain right places, at certain right times, and then life gets complicated in some whole other way after that wonderful moment.
我的意思是，命运把你放在某些正确的地方，在某些正确的时间，然后在那美妙的时刻之后，生活会以完全不同的方式变得复杂。
I always love that, that Kierkegaard quote that I think is really, I sound like Ted right now, but it's a really, it's so appropriate for how I met my mother that life can only be understood backward, but you have to live it forward.
我一直很喜欢克尔凯郭尔的那句话，我觉得这句话真的，我现在听起来就像特德，但这真的非常适合我如何认识我的母亲，生活只能向后理解，但你必须向前生活。
Yeah, and yeah, that's the show.
是啊，是啊，这就是节目。
So you get both of them in there.
所以你把他们两个都放在那里。
Which we quoted that in the pitch.
我们在演讲中引用了这一点。
You get older Ted who knows where all this is headed.
随着年龄的增长，泰德知道这一切的走向。
He knows all the twists and turns and he knows how he landed on his feet.
他知道所有的曲折，也知道他是如何站稳脚跟的。
And then the Ted that I was playing doesn't know any of that.
然后我扮演的 Ted 对此一无所知。
The Ted that I was playing was like, This is the worst night of my life, or this is calamitous, this is never, I'm done, I'm not gonna be successful.
我扮演的泰德就像是，这是我一生中最糟糕的夜晚，或者这是灾难性的，这永远不会，我受够了，我不会成功。
I'm not gonna have a family, like all of these things.
我不会有一个家庭，就像所有这些事情一样。
I sometimes, I used to think about like if you, this is a weird thought experiment, but it pertains to the show.
有时我会想，如果你的话，这是一个奇怪的思想实验，但它与节目有关。
If you were a molecule in a cell and you were like sentient, like you could, you knew you were a molecule in a cell and you could be interviewed.
如果你是细胞中的一个分子，并且你就像有感知能力一样，你就知道你是细胞中的一个分子，你可以接受采访。
And so I said, what's it like being a molecule in this cell?
所以我说，作为这个细胞中的一个分子是什么样的？
You'd be like, it's insane, man.
你会说，这太疯狂了，伙计。
I'm getting knocked around.
我快被打晕了。
Like, I don't know what's going on.
就像，我不知道发生了什么事。
It's just anarchy in here.
这里只是无政府状态。
But the scientist looking through a microscope sees that there's a real order to what's going on in that cell and that molecule has a destiny of some sort.
但通过显微镜观察的科学家发现，细胞中发生的事情确实有顺序，并且该分子具有某种命运。
Like, it's going to, right?
就像，它会的，对吧？
But from the perspective of the molecule, it doesn't know that.
但从分子的角度来看，它并不知道这一点。
And I always thought that was kind of like how I made my mother like, Ted was the molecule getting knocked around inside the cell.
我一直认为这有点像我让我母亲喜欢的方式，特德是细胞内被撞击的分子。
But then the older Ted was kind of the scientist who was like, no, no, no, I see how this is all coalescing and gathering steam and making sense.
但年长的特德就像一位科学家，他说，不，不，不，我看到这一切是如何融合在一起、聚集在一起并有意义的。
You know?
你知道？
Yeah, and I think like Destiny in the world of the show to me is like the gratitude you feel for your life looking back and realizing that even the hard parts had to happen and they made you who you are and you survived them and you became who you are now and you're happy to be.
是的，我认为这部剧世界中的《命运》对我来说就像是你对自己的生活的感激之情，当你回顾自己的生活时，意识到即使是困难的部分也必须发生，它们造就了你，你熬过了它们，你成为了现在的你，你很高兴成为这样的人。
And you only achieve Destiny when you're content to where you are and you're accepting where you are.
只有当你对自己所处的位置感到满意并接受自己的位置时，你才能实现命运。
And when you're young, it's hard to feel that.
当你年轻的时候，很难有这种感觉。
Yeah, and also I think because we live in such a kind of insanely upbeat and optimistic culture where we're shadowed denying and death denying and pain and suffering denying, if you really ask people, what were the most meaningful moments of your life?
是的，而且我认为，因为我们生活在一种极其乐观的文化中，我们被否认、否认死亡、否认痛苦和苦难所笼罩，如果你真的问人们，你一生中最有意义的时刻是什么？
They often involve struggle and heartbreak and set back an unexpected turn of events, right?
它们常常涉及斗争和心碎，并让事情发生意想不到的转变，对吗？
They're never like a graduate from business school I met the girl in my dreams and I had no problem.
他们从来都不像商学院的毕业生，我在梦中遇到了那个女孩，我没有遇到任何问题。
That's not what Forge is character, both in the larger sense of the word character and in this specific sense, Forge is these characters.
这并不是 Forge 所代表的角色，无论是在角色这个词的更广泛意义上，还是在这个特定的意义上，Forge 就是这些角色。
So I think that dual kind of consciousness of watching people live forward not knowing how this is going to unfold and being quite scared but doing the best they could and then the older perspective of almost like he's watching himself and saying, keep going, kid.
所以我认为，这种双重意识是看着人们向前生活，不知道事情会如何发展，非常害怕，但会尽力而为，然后从旧的角度看，就像他在看着自己说，继续前进，孩子。
it's going to, you know, almost like me talking to myself, when I watched the pilot, like, hey, hey, you were, you did okay.
你知道，这几乎就像我自言自语，当我观看飞行员时，就像，嘿，嘿，你是，你做得很好。
You did okay.
你做得很好。
You landed on your feet.
你双脚着地。
So, Craig, did we officially or did you officially rename the pilot the blue french horn?
那么，克雷格，我们正式还是您正式将飞行员重新命名为蓝色圆号？
In my mind, I did.
在我看来，我做到了。
How did I go?
我怎么去的？
Is there a time machine so I can go do that?
有时光机让我可以去那儿吗？
It should have been called that.
应该这么称呼。
I can admit it now.
我现在可以承认了。
The one to punch a blue french horn and purple giraffe would I mean, you might have colors, it's all colors, you might have wanted every episode to have a color in it.
我的意思是，打蓝色法国号和紫色长颈鹿的那个，你可能有颜色，都是颜色，你可能希望每一集都有一种颜色。
That damn it.
真该死。
Every fucking pilot's called pilot and we should just need that to be retcon, I don't know what to do about it.
每个该死的飞行员都被称为飞行员，我们只需要进行侦察即可，我不知道该怎么办。
All right, I'll talk to the studio.
好的，我去跟工作室谈谈。
They made that time machine.
他们制造了那台时光机。
Well, before recording this episode, we asked you on Instagram from at how we made your mother.
好吧，在录制本集之前，我们在 Instagram 上询问了您的问题：我们是如何创造您的母亲的。
If you had any questions about the pilot, by the time we had finished recording, an hour later.
如果您对试播集有任何疑问，当我们在一小时后完成录制时。
over 300 questions.
超过 300 个问题。
So thank you for sending those questions in.
感谢您发送这些问题。
So we can announce now that you can look forward to bonus episodes that we are calling general questions, general questions, general questions, where we rapid fire go through as many of your questions as we can.
因此，我们现在可以宣布，您可以期待我们称之为一般问题、一般问题、一般问题的奖励剧集，我们将尽可能多地快速解答您的问题。
We'll be doing that each week.
我们每周都会这样做。
So just look out on Instagram for posting, asking you to submit those questions.
因此，请留意 Instagram 上的帖子，要求您提交这些问题。
but also on the website, we're collecting your stories.
我们还在网站上收集您的故事。
These are stories of how you discovered, how I met your mother, hard times I got you through.
这些故事讲述了你如何发现，我如何遇见你母亲，以及我如何帮助你度过难关。
Generally, what how I met your mother means to you.
一般来说，我如何认识你母亲对你来说意味着什么。
So go to www.howwemadeyourmother.com, click on contact to submit your story.
因此，请访问 www.howwemadeyourmother.com，点击“联系方式”提交您的故事。
And here is an amazing one.
这是一个令人惊奇的事情。
This is from Nephthes, from Paris.
这是来自巴黎的 Nephthes。
Oh, this is like the greatest thing We've ever had this.
哦，这就像我们经历过的最伟大的事情。
This is the one we cheated and we read ahead on this one.
这是我们作弊的，我们提前阅读了这一点。
Yeah, this is yeah, this is quite an Extraordinary letter.
是的，这是是的，这是一封非常特别的信。
So we are so grateful for you Nefty's from I hope I'm pronouncing it correctly.
所以我们非常感谢你 Nefty's from 我希望我的发音正确。
I know.
我知道。
I don't know what to say.
我不知道该说什么。
Nefty's from Paris sending this in salute I was 12 years old the first time I stumbled upon how I met your mother it was 2013 I was with my brother's girlfriends little sister.
来自巴黎的 Nefty 向您致以敬意 我 12 岁时第一次偶然发现我是如何遇见你母亲的，那是 2013 年，当时我和我哥哥的女朋友的小妹妹在一起。
We were very close friends.
我们是非常亲密的朋友。
We had no money me and spent our time inventing games, lives, and careers for ourselves.
我们没有钱，把时间花在为自己发明游戏、生活和职业上。
She had a tiny purple couch with green stripes, and sometimes we could watch series and movies on a tiny cathode-ray TV that her mother had found at a flea market, if I remember correctly.
她有一张带有绿色条纹的紫色小沙发，如果我没记错的话，有时我们可以在她母亲在跳蚤市场找到的一台小型阴极射线电视上观看连续剧和电影。
That's where we discovered our love for sitcoms, especially how I met your mother.
这就是我们发现自己对情景喜剧的热爱的地方，尤其是我是如何认识你母亲的。
I love how the scene is set.
我喜欢场景的设置。
I love the description of the couch.
我喜欢对沙发的描述。
I'm already in.
我已经进去了
This series has been with me for so many years.
这个系列已经陪伴我很多年了。
I watch it when I'm happy, when I'm sad, when I'm sick, and when I'm perfectly fine.
当我快乐的时候、当我悲伤的时候、当我生病的时候、当我完全好的时候，我都会看它。
I didn't grow up in a functional, happy, or loving family.
我并不是在一个正常的、幸福的、充满爱的家庭中长大的。
How I met your mother taught me that this wasn't a life sentence.
我认识你母亲的经历告诉我这不是无期徒刑。
That home is wherever you choose to make it.
那个家就是你选择的地方。
My home wasn't a place of shouting in tears, even if that's where I was born.
我的家不是一个哭泣的地方，即使那是我出生的地方。
My home can be anywhere with anyone, and I build it every day with that thought in my heart.
我的家可以在任何地方，与任何人在一起，我每天都怀着这样的想法建造它。
This show taught me not to give up and to cherish what brings joy in life.
这个节目教会了我不要放弃并珍惜生活中带来的快乐。
Today I'm 23 years old, I live in Paris, and I'm a young journalist who meets her friends several times a week at the same bars, tells the same stories on repeat, makes the same jokes and talks about love with her group in every conversation.
今天，我 23 岁了，我住在巴黎，我是一名年轻的记者，每周在同一家酒吧与她的朋友见面几次，重复讲述相同的故事，讲相同的笑话，并在每次谈话中与她的团队谈论爱。
When I'm surrounded by this family I chose, sometimes often, I think of you.
当我被这个我选择的家庭包围时，有时我会经常想起你。
I tell myself that without this show, I might never have managed to escape the toxic environment I grew up in.
我告诉自己，如果没有这个节目，我可能永远无法摆脱我成长的有毒环境。
I once shared my love for how I met your mother the dear friend.
我曾经分享过我对如何认识你母亲这位亲爱的朋友的爱。
Our teenage days were filled with references, singing bang, bang, bang, adi bang at the top of our lungs, throwing slap bets left and right, granting each other favors without question and using weight for it in every sense.
我们的青少年时代充满了参考资料，用尽全力唱着“砰、砰、砰、阿迪砰”，左右打赌，毫无疑问地互相给予对方好处，并在各种意义上使用重量。
That friendship changed my life so intense, so complicated that even though it ended long ago, I will always think of her whenever I think of you.
那段友谊如此强烈、如此复杂地改变了我的生活，即使它早已结束，但每当我想起你时，我总会想起她。
One night we slept over at each other's place and in the morning, she left an unexpected gift, an unspoken message.
一天晚上，我们在彼此的住处过夜，早上，她留下了一份意想不到的礼物，一条无言的信息。
She placed a pineapple on my nightstand, and I understood.
她在我的床头柜上放了一个菠萝，我明白了。
My first love gave me a blue French horn necklace for our first Valentine's Day.
我的初恋情人在我们的第一个情人节送给了我一条蓝色法国号项链。
I made him watch every season any cried for hours at the end.
我让他看每一季，最后都会哭上几个小时。
I have forced dozens of people to watch this series and I've never left anyone unaffected.
我已经强迫几十个人观看这个系列节目，而且我从来没有让任何人不受影响。
Because that's how I met your mother represents to me.
因为这就是我认识你母亲的方式。
Every person who has known me has heard me talk about this show, and every person who no longer knows me will think of me when whenever they hear its name.
每个认识我的人都听过我谈论过这个节目，每个不认识我的人一听到它的名字就会想起我。
I grew up with you at McLaren's and I will never stop being grateful for what you have given me.
我和您一起在迈凯伦车队长大，我将永远感激您所给予我的一切。
Thank you, Marshall, for teaching me that kindness is the key to all relationships.
谢谢你，马歇尔，你教会我善良是所有关系的关键。
Thank you, Lily, for teaching me to be a loyal friend, always there for my loved ones without losing myself in the process.
谢谢你，莉莉，教会我成为一个忠诚的朋友，永远陪伴在我所爱的人身边，同时又不会在这个过程中迷失自我。
Thank you, Robin, for teaching me that in the end, you have to be able to rely on yourself.
谢谢你，罗宾，你教会了我，最终你必须能够依靠自己。
Thank you, Barney, for reminding me how important it is to have fun.
谢谢你，巴尼，提醒我玩得开心是多么重要。
Thank you, Ted, for showing me that everything should be done with love, never out of fear.
谢谢你，特德，让我知道一切都应该用爱来完成，而不是出于恐惧。
Thank you all for everything.
谢谢大家所做的一切。
You have been with me for two thirds of my life and this journey will likely never end.
你陪伴了我三分之二的人生，这段旅程可能永远不会结束。
I could write for hours more, but it's already late.
我可以再写几个小时，但已经晚了。
And as we all know, nothing good ever happens after two AM.
众所周知，凌晨两点之后就不会发生任何好事。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Wow.
哇。
I got choked up the first time I read that and I got choked up listening to it just now.
我第一次读到这个的时候就哽咽了，现在再听也哽咽了。
Beautiful, beautiful.
美丽，美丽。
That is why we made the show.
这就是我们制作这个节目的原因。
Thank you for that beautiful message.
谢谢你的美丽留言。
Really, really moved hearing that, really moved.
听了真的很感动，真的很感动。
Yeah, I've read it a few times and I'm stunned at the sincerity and the, you know, I think back of like movies and TV, like sometimes it's filled with toxic silly nonsense.
是的，我读过几次，我对它的诚意感到震惊，你知道，我回想起电影和电视，有时它充满了有毒的愚蠢的废话。
And some of this show was too.
这个节目的一些内容也是如此。
And we're atoning for that.
我们正在为此赎罪。
But a lot of, you know, I learned how, like, I mean, I learned how to, you know, talk to women or even talk to friends.
但很多，你知道，我学会了如何，我的意思是，我学会了如何，你知道，与女人交谈，甚至与朋友交谈。
Like, there was so much that I learned from television and learned from, you know, when you fall in love with a TV series or fall in love with a movie.
就像，我从电视中学到了很多东西，你知道，当你爱上电视剧或爱上电影时，我学到了很多东西。
I mean, it was so trippy for me.
我的意思是，这对我来说太迷幻了。
Like, I was such a fan of that first karate kid movie.
就像，我是第一部空手道小子电影的粉丝。
Like, to have Billy's abka and Ralph Nachio on the show like they're on my phone now.
就像，让比利的阿布卡和拉尔夫·纳奇奥出现在节目中，就像他们现在在我的手机上一样。
Like I really like those guys.
就像我真的很喜欢那些家伙一样。
They're fantastic.
他们太棒了。
They're great.
他们很棒。
Yeah, I mean, just the trippiness of that.
是的，我的意思是，这就是迷幻。
But that move, I mean, talk about, I mean, Elizabeth Schoole, I was like my first crush or one of my first crushes like in that movie, I just remember how much I learned from film and TV.
但我的意思是，谈论这一举动，我的意思是，伊丽莎白·斯库勒，我就像我的第一次迷恋或我第一次迷恋的人，就像那部电影一样，我只记得我从电影和电视中学到了多少东西。
And again, not all of it was great lessons.
再说一次，并非所有这些都是很好的教训。
I had to unlearn some of those lessons, but it's so incredible to be a part of a show that takes up permanent residents within people's hearts and psyches and I'm just really stunned by it.
我不得不忘记其中的一些教训，但能够成为一部永久居民在人们内心和心灵中的节目的一部分真是太不可思议了，我真的对此感到震惊。
It is stunning.
这是令人惊叹的。
It's stunning.
太棒了。
That's the word.
就是这个词。
I feel stunned by it and to have a fan like that who really got what the show was and then brought it around to all of these other people.
我对此感到震惊，并拥有这样的粉丝，他们真正理解了这部剧的内涵，然后将其传播给所有其他人。
I mean, that is the dream.
我的意思是，这就是梦想。
To cool to show.
炫酷地展示。
That's the dream.
这就是梦想。
That's why we made the show.
这就是我们制作这个节目的原因。
It was kind of a message in the bottle to find somebody exactly like this wonderful person who shared this message and part where they said it wasn't a life sentence to grow up in a hard place and a hard time and a hard home to grow up and then realize that it's not a life sentence that you can find a family and then sort of within this little letter of flashing forward to Paris in 23 years old and a young journalist who meets her friends several times a week at the bar and is kind of living her version of how much your mother, it's just so epic and scope the show kind of carried through that timeline of her life and just to think of it being an important part of that journey and getting and giving faith and hope and something to look forward to and realizing you're not stuck in a bad situation.
这是一种瓶子里的信息，找到一个与这个美妙的人一模一样的人分享了这个信息，他们说在一个艰难的地方、艰难的时光和艰难的家庭中长大并不是无期徒刑，然后意识到这不是无期徒刑，你可以找到一个家庭，然后在这封小信中，23岁的她突然来到了巴黎，一个年轻的记者每周在酒吧与她的朋友见面几次，生活在她的版本中，你的母亲有多少，这部剧的史诗般的规模和范围贯穿了她一生的时间线，只是想想它是这段旅程的重要组成部分，获得并给予信心和希望，以及一些值得期待的东西，并意识到你并没有陷入糟糕的境地。
You can you can choose your way into better situations and you know the idea that the show inspired that is is really amazing thank you for sharing that That's it.
你可以选择进入更好的情况的方式，你知道这个节目所激发的想法真是太棒了，谢谢你分享，就是这样。
It also strikes me, Craig.
这也让我印象深刻，克雷格。
It's like, you know how there's that kind of, I mean, speaking of Star Wars, which you know a lot better than I do, but like that kind of charge where people say like fans understand the series better than George Lucas does at some like cellular level.
就像，你知道，我的意思是，谈到《星球大战》，你比我更了解它，但就像人们说的那样，粉丝比乔治·卢卡斯在细胞层面上更了解这个系列。
Like, not that you and Carter don't understand this show, I just feel like at some point when a show permeates into the culture, it's actually belongs to the fans more than it belongs to the people who created it.
就像，并不是说你和卡特不理解这个节目，我只是觉得在某个时刻，当一个节目渗透到文化中时，它实际上更多地属于粉丝，而不是属于创造它的人。
And the fans actually are going to have insight into things and make connections and draw like certain parallels that you didn't even see or themes that they can tease out that they've watched it so much.
粉丝们实际上会对事物有洞察力，建立联系，并画出某些你甚至没有看到的相似之处，或者他们可以梳理出他们已经看了很多次的主题。
I mean genuinely when people come up to me and say I've seen the show 17 times like I have not seen all these episodes like they know this show way better than I know this show or they'll throw like an old joke at me and I'm like I don't know what that is.
我的意思是说，当人们来找我，说我已经看过这个节目 17 遍了，就像我没有看过所有这些剧集一样，他们比我更了解这个节目，或者他们会像一个老笑话一样对我扔，我就像我不知道那是什么。
And they're like, they think I'm lying.
他们认为我在撒谎。
Like they think that it's like part of my like DNA.
就像他们认为这是我 DNA 的一部分一样。
That, you know, I don't like, I don't remember that.
你知道，我不喜欢，我不记得了。
It was, it was, it was 2008, but it does feel like the fans own it.
那是，那是，那是2008年，但确实感觉球迷拥有它。
It's theirs, you know, and in some ways we're going back and saying to the fans, hey, tell us what this thing is that we made.
这是他们的，你知道，在某些方面我们会回去对粉丝们说，嘿，告诉我们我们做了什么。
Tell us what this is.
告诉我们这是什么。
That is what, that's what this whole podcast is.
这就是整个播客的内容。
I'm loving it so much because at the time I identified, I over-identified with it.
我非常喜欢它，因为当我认同它时，我过度认同它。
I thought, this is me.
我想，这就是我。
This is the, you know, I am only identified by this thing we're making in this moment in my 30s and this is my shot and this is every up and down.
你知道，这就是我在 30 多岁时唯一能通过我们正在制作的东西来识别的东西，这是我的镜头，这是每一次的起起落落。
I'll take it all like it's me, I'll feel like I've failed if it's not great, et cetera, over, you know, the lows are always lower than the highs but you'll be, you identify entirely by it.
我会像我一样接受这一切，如果不是很好，我会觉得自己失败了，等等，结束了，你知道，低点总是低于高点，但你会，你完全通过它来识别。
There's such freedom and just what a gift to realize It's so much bigger than any one person.
如此自由，意识到它比任何一个人都伟大得多，这真是一份礼物。
It's not me, with the show finished 10, 11 years ago now, and it's finding people and it's becoming theirs.
不是我，这部剧已经在十、十一年前结束了，它正在寻找人们，它正在成为他们的。
And to go back into it from outside now and experiencing it through the fans eyes and realizing what it meant to people, it's a humbling in the best possible way.
现在从外面回到这里，通过球迷的眼睛体验它，并意识到它对人们意味着什么，这是一种最好的谦卑。
It makes me feel so small.
这让我感觉自己是如此的渺小。
And like, it was our job just to channel this bigger thing, capture it in this moment of time where we're so lucky I'll be in the same place at the same time, picking up on the same radio of signal together from the universe and sort of channel it into this thing, send it out into the world and see what happens.
就像，我们的工作就是引导这个更大的东西，在这个时刻捕捉它，我们很幸运，我会在同一时间在同一个地方，从宇宙中一起接收同一个无线电信号，并将其引导到这个东西中，将其发送到世界上，看看会发生什么。
And this is the part where we get to see what happened.
这是我们可以看到发生了什么的部分。
And it's wonderful.
这太棒了。
I am guilty.
我有罪。
Please equip me.
请装备我。
All sins are forgiven.
所有的罪孽都被宽恕了。
New York City.
纽约市。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任监制。
The show was produced by me, Alec Webb.
该剧由我亚历克·韦伯制作。
And our co-producer is Doug Matica.
我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves。
Artwork by John Marrow.
约翰·马罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner, special thanks to Lowly Kennedy and Elliott Connards.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的 NYC，特别感谢 Lowly Kennedy 和 Elliott Connards。
Visit howwemadeyourmother.com to sign up for our sub-stack mailing list and for links to our social media.
请访问 howwemadeyourmother.com 注册我们的子堆栈邮件列表以及我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
您还可以单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Riders' newsletters on Substack.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Riders 的时事通讯。
Read Craig Thomas' published prose at Craig Thomas Writer.com.
阅读 Craig Thomas 在 Craig Thomas Writer.com 上发表的散文。
And you can subscribe to my dead father's society also on Substack.
您也可以在 Substack 上订阅我已故父亲的社团。
To learn about how you make a difference, This shows ongoing campaign to raise money for a congenital heart disease research.
要了解您如何做出改变，这展示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动。
Check out the Make It Difference tab at the top of our website.
查看我们网站顶部的“Make It Difference”选项卡。
This episode was made possible by the support of backyard ventures, marketing provided by Tink Media.
这一集是在 Backyard Ventures 的支持和 Tink Media 的营销支持下得以实现的。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。
The real question, it just hit me.
真正的问题，它刚刚击中了我。
Am I in love with you?
我爱你吗？
Or just New York's?
还是只是纽约的？